foreign
I said yeah everybody must be in a good
mood today even though it's [__]
Monday that's terrible but you know
maybe they're just trying to like hype
themselves up and feel better you know I
was listening to that relaxing Countdown
music though boom boom
time's the time's having a Moment of Zen
yeah I was like oh I love this show
oh my God yeah
man I love this show oh that's right
it's my show yeah
yeah it's [__] fun it's not here it
all the time
yeah I don't usually I don't usually
usually watch our shows back yeah unless
it's something that we're
you know what I mean like if I kind of
have to skip through like an old one
like if we're doing a revisit on
something but you know they're all
piling in I know gang's all here damn
where were y'all last weekend
well what when do we stream oh we
streamed yesterday we talked about the
Tom Cruise movie yeah maybe people
didn't give a [__] about time he wasn't
a lot there then and then um Friday was
uh kind of dead
oh yeah yeah maybe everybody left
because of all the porny talk yeah I
talked about porn
about our porn career
are burgeoning yeah
y'all are [__] buying up our videos
all that [__] we got posted up on our
stream mate profile
it's just flying off the shelf and we
know that that's not stream made people
buying it because they don't really know
who we are we've only been on we've only
three to stream three times
so we know that's y'all y'all pervs
behind that [__] no I I uploaded a
couple more but I don't I don't know if
they've been approved yet like I said
they're real
I had one last one from uh the one from
yesterday and then the one that remember
that that one with the weird with the
weird dicks and it's like they kept
saying it's like oh there's an
unauthorized person because your voice
was in it yeah and I kept going through
there and being like I don't hear it I
don't hear it but then like when I went
through it again just now I was like oh
you there when you said something yeah
okay like that was like really quiet
I didn't catch that the first time so I
edited that out yeah AI finds that so
I'm gonna try and upload it again the
one week the one we cut last night is
probably one of the best videos Jen's
ever done I mean I hope it came out okay
because I had special effects and
everything well I don't know I was
running the special effects
this dick was skeeting and shooting and
[__] with all the fake [__] it was all
getting all over her glasses and
everything it looked beautiful look real
I had to blow it up some because my hand
kept Reaching Your Hands yeah I was
running two cameras at once
had a little camera tripod you zoomed in
though to get get that Cabinetry yeah
but like I said I uploaded it so we'll
see if there because they seem like real
uh picky it's not them it's AI it's a
computer it's like yeah whose hand is
this or whose voice is that anything any
anything any voice that's not the I mean
in this case not the account holder is
uh the thing's flagged right because
it's not authorized so AI is real good
at
recognizing voices and body parts and
faces so I had to keep like bloated and
like moving it around a little bit like
to get his hand out of it because his
hand was like in the corner I don't know
how it [__] knows there's been a real
dick and a fake dick though
yeah I don't know that either well like
I don't know
because sometimes things look realistic
right
well that's what I was kind of worried
about with this one yeah I don't know
we'll see how it goes
we'll see how it goes but uh no that's
shit's selling
and uh I think everything everything we
put up is sold
thank you very much Sean Robertson hey
guys how's it been got back into
painting and I'm trying to paint the
cemetery painting from Night Gallery
awesome yeah yeah keeping with the Ghost
theme of tonight are you gonna do the
one I mean do the scariest one where
like the dude is like coming out of the
coffin or he's coming up toward the the
house you know what I mean because it
was like a whole series of them of
paintings but that's like Kick-Ass I
really like a lot of those Night Gallery
paintings not gonna lie if somebody had
them online I could probably like print
them out and just like put them in
little frames
so
make posters on yeah I like make posters
of them I don't think anybody probably
anybody has like high-res ones other
than the artist but you could kind of do
little ones or do like a collage or
something because some of them are
really awesome I still need to do
I did um a video and a post over on my
scare Salon site about the first uh I
did the pilot of Night Gallery and I did
the first season but I have I forgot
about that I have the um box set
so I have season two and season three so
I need to get into doing that because I
need to do a season two I forgot to ask
you what what's that on that last edit
you did first of all I couldn't find out
what in what folder that was in on on
Dropbox I could well I haven't no I
didn't put the edited version in Dropbox
just the Rob one is okay you gotta get
the edited version in there too I want a
copy okay well like I said I just I just
finished editing it and then like I
uploaded it to streaming I wanted to ask
you were you able to take out that
mechanical noise during a special effect
yeah okay yeah that wasn't a problem I
think well I mean I just like lowered
the volume like just kind of okay
because she was making all kinds of
noise yeah I know all right I know what
I'm doing yeah hopefully
but the edit and all the camera angles
and everything it worked out yeah like I
said it came out it came out okay like I
said I had to blow it up so it's not
like super high definition or anything
like that you've got all the up shots
and everything well I didn't put all of
that in there yeah yeah I put some of
that in there but I want to see it well
like I said I only just did it it's like
you know I don't have a lot of time you
know I wasn't home all day
so I I did it real quick and then it's
like just I uploaded it but I haven't
uploaded it to Dropbox or anything like
that you know all right it was one of
these days like I said one of these days
I'm gonna teach you how to use that yeah
so I could do it yeah
it's not it's not complicated I use um
Wonder shelf wondershare filmora yeah
and it's pretty it's just it's like I
said it's not difficult it's just
tedious and you gotta line up the audio
Yeah it's just tedious okay so audio
came from uh both cameras or one camera
no I didn't do it like that I just
there's no audio there's yeah no that's
not what I meant I meant there's audio
but it's just like it wasn't it didn't
really matter because like I wasn't
really talking or anything like that so
I just kind of so it didn't matter you
just whatever the shot was whatever the
shot was that was yeah that was the
audio Yeah Yeah you know it's fine like
I said I know what I'm doing
hopefully it sounds good
you use noise reduction huh you did
noise reduction
I do it on there sometimes but you can't
do it too much or it'll make everything
sound real tinny okay all right you know
so like I said a lot of times I usually
just kind of leave like a regular room
tone because it sounds like more natural
more natural all right you know you're
right I want to see it
but yeah I'm just well I'm just saying I
had to do it like really quick so you
know what I mean all right I don't have
a long time to [__] around with yeah
they're all because they're all in here
now
all right so finally we're gonna get to
the ghost story stuff uh and this one uh
this is season seven one this is episode
number four evil Never Dies now I will
say and I think I might have mentioned
this before but as the seasons went on
uh particularly in into season seven
they tried to make it more like I said
more cinematic but another thing I
noticed too and you can see it from the
length of my notes from earlier episodes
and the length of the notes from the
later episodes is that
there was substantially less content
like a lot of this stuff was repeated
you know what I mean like because they
started doing the thing where
you know they'd be like oh all this [__]
happened and then it would be like
commercial break and then it would come
back and then they would reiterate like
a bunch of [__] that just happened like
let's do a you know let's do like a
summation of everything that's happened
up till now I'm like yeah but we already
had all that information like but I feel
like they did that because they didn't
have as much material so they were
trying to like stretch it out you know
what I mean because I mean sometimes
on the older shows I had like five pages
of notes this one I have like one page
front and back and then one page that's
it you know what I mean because a lot of
it was just like repeating stuff that
had already happened
so that's that's all but this was like a
pretty good I liked this one because one
uh it was kind of unusual in the sense
that they didn't get the church involved
and nobody said anything about demons
which is nice
um it just seemed like in this one it
seemed like a a ghost but the ghost was
just like a dick you know what I mean
nobody said anything about demons or
portals or anything like that I actually
like this episode yeah
and I really liked the uh the ghosts
that they had I thought it was like
really creepy looking looked a little
bit like Torah Johnson
um yeah a little bit
um especially like that part in in um uh
playing time from outer space where he's
like climbing out of the thing with the
white eyes you know what I mean like in
the grave he kind of this particular
episode the way it's shot and just the
things that happen and it kind of
reminded me of like the first four
seasons it was kind of like something
out of there and another the way it was
told but it was shot better
yeah
yeah definitely yeah Tammy says uh it's
in Jacksonville yeah this was actually
in Florida this one uh Pensacola
which is uh North Florida I've actually
never been to Pensacola even though I've
lived I don't think
even though I've lived in uh Florida my
whole life that's damn near Alabama I
think uh it is yeah yeah it is I think
it's up in the Panhandle yeah that's
what I said it's basically Alabama yeah
it's right across the Alabama Board I
think
yeah if I remember correctly because I
remember on the coast of Mississippi we
used to mention Pensacola all the time
and that I don't I think that was only
like an hour or so away yeah hours away
you know Coastline of Alabama's small I
don't think I honestly I have never been
um I've been in North Florida obviously
I've been to Jacksonville because my mom
used to live there and I've been out of
Florida like I've driven out of Florida
and like into Georgia and like up into
Baltimore and stuff but um you know so
I've driven through a lot of states
but I have have never been
driven into the panhandle of Florida
it's like Mississippi yeah I know I've
heard but I've never been more trailer
parks yeah a lot of trailer parks I've
been to South Florida like I've been to
Fort Lauderdale and Miami and [__] like
that but I've never been to the Keys
either now that I think about it I
should probably go one of these days but
yeah I've never been up in the Panhandle
at all but yeah so this one um because I
mean Florida is massive yeah people
don't realize big difference between say
Panhandle Orlando area where we are at
and [__] Miami there's a huge
difference that's like different
countries
yeah pretty much and we mentioned that
before like the other parts of Florida
are like I mean it's still Florida you
know what I mean but um it there's a lot
of difference a lot of differences
sections of it yeah
well like I said you know you're gonna
go to the Panhandle it's anglos it's
like people from Mississippi it's like
white people from Mississippi
you go down to Miami man that's that's
almost that's almost like North Cuba
it's like yeah eventually yeah it's more
like Central America
and they've been there forever
they were there before before there was
the United States back when when this
was the Spanish Empire you know
Florida's old real old it's older than
the United States
well yeah like I said all you have to do
is go to St Augustine and see that right
because that was there hundreds of years
before
but um I mean some of those buildings
were 1500s yeah that was built here
1500s
okay so yeah so this one took place in
Pensacola which I thought was kind of
neat
um they they took care Dimension several
times during the course of this show
that the house where all of this takes
place was a million dollar mansion a
million dollar house they kept saying
that I think he said it like three or
four times
it's like see you could even have a
million dollar house and it'll still
your [__] will still be haunted by ghost
I guess that was the implication there
it was like ghostly even on a million
and actually if I was a ghost I would
much rather haunt a million dollar
mansion than some [__] rundown
trailer park someplace yeah I mean
wouldn't you in Pensacola a million
dollars are [__] bias a huge ass
Mansion too I mean the house that they
had on this episode was nice but it
wasn't like super over the top I'd like
to see what the house really looked like
yeah I mean I'm sure it was a million
then there's a lot in it yeah it was
probably an old Victorian
I would imagine a giant old Victorian
yeah money eater
well yeah they just eat up your money
but you eat them are cool yeah
I mean it's probably better like if you
build a mansion nowadays obviously with
all the you know [__] that all the
technology they have now it's much
better but yeah and those old houses are
kind of a million dollars get you a hell
of a mcmansion if you got enough
property to put it on
it won't last long but they're not
designed to last long you know the
modern construction materials is pretty
cheap they look good though
yeah yeah murder Hornet uh this is a
call back to a discussion we had on on
several shows ago uh it says I
accidentally slipped and my cat went up
my ass yeah
yeah
I'm sure I'm sure that's happened
somewhere yeah show up to the emergency
room I was walking how did they get up
in there I was walking and and I tripped
yeah and I landed on that shampoo bottle
yeah yeah
uh Camp guys talking about Destin Destin
Florida uh Destin is a huge high-end
Resort place now uh destination very
high-end developments and Golf and
Tennis clubs yeah yeah
um where's that the band handle
I thought that that was over on the west
coast but I could be wrong about that I
can't remember where it's at
um he says all the way from Panama City
Beach to Destin is very high density
high-end retail townhouses strip malls
every three quarters of a mile I could
barely drive a pickup truck between all
the condos and townhouses yeah
highest density Development I've ever
seen here in Florida yet I thought yeah
I thought it was over on the west coast
like over in the Tampa area but it might
be in South Florida actually another
thing it's like I've lived in Florida my
whole life but I can't remember all the
[__] cities are because you know what
I mean I'm pretty familiar with like
Central Florida
um because that's generally where where
our stomping grounds are but other than
that like I know the names of the Cities
I'm like I can't quite remember where
that's at you know what I mean yeah for
you Europeans and maybe listening to us
or people in other countries United
States is not really a country it's a
[__] planet all right it's almost
totally enclosed each state is like its
own country some of these states are
kind of like three countries joined and
these people don't really don't give a
[__] about what's happening outside the
United States they couldn't Point
anything in a map they couldn't name
most of the other countries if you were
to point at them in a map it's just it's
a it's its own planet
yeah you just point to it and they're
just like that's just foreign yeah
foreigners
you can point to just any country any
country in Europe they would just over
and over again over and over again just
say yeah that's England yeah that's it
that's also that one's England that's
probably Germany what about that one I
think that's England
[Laughter]
one called France over there
that's way over here yeah they're
pointing to like [__] Japan or
something they would recognize Russia
they would recognize Russia but you say
where's China they would be able to
point it out probably not nope
I used to be quite good at geography
back in the day but you know
all right so yeah uh so Pensacola a
million dollar mansion they really
wanted you to know on Escambia Bay
which is uh quite a famous body of water
here in Florida
so this start this all stuff started in
summer of 2009.
so the woman at the center of this is
named Jennifer I think they said her
last name was well burn I'm pretty sure
that that's what the none of these
haunting DVDs have closed captioning so
I guess they were just kind of like [__]
you deaf people pretty much
um I don't know about the later ones
like because we bought like digitally we
bought we have season eight
and we bought season 11. I know we
bought two seasons like on Amazon Prime
I know we have eight but that's only
four episodes yeah and then I think we
bought season 11. there's a new one up
there we haven't bought yet right yeah I
think there's it goes up to season 12.
there's a couple but there's a couple
Seasons that they like I think season
nine I don't think they have it like
it's up there but then when you click on
it it says not available yeah but we do
have we do have season eight though and
eleven is up there we haven't bought it
yet right they had to buy it just for
shits and giggles and look at it yeah we
actually started re-watching season
eight the other day but then I realized
I was like oh [__] there's only four
episodes what's that all about yeah and
I remembered them as soon as I saw him I
did too yeah because we watched him not
that long ago I think that's why because
I mean we lived in this house when we
bought that so it has not been hasn't
been that long it's just been like a
year maybe not even that long
so yeah they were all very familiar so
yeah so her name is Jennifer I'm pretty
sure they said it was Wellborn so for a
while I guess she was a single mom and
she had two daughters whose name is her
Lauren and Candace and Lauren was 18 at
the time and Candace was 17.
now so I guess she'd been raising them
on her own for a long time but then she
reconnects with her high school
sweetheart whose name is Jamie he was
also uh interviewed on here as well and
they got engaged and moved to this big
ass mansion in Pensacola
and you know the girls love him and he's
the father figure of bloody blah so
Escambia Bay if you don't know uh which
is I I'm assuming the way they were
talking the house was right on the bay
um you know what I mean so I don't know
exactly where this house is at but yeah
so Escambia Bay um kind of well known
for uh like a lot of stuff in the slave
trade so that kind of plays into the
story like later on
so they move into this house now two
weeks after they move in the first thing
that Jennifer said that she noticed was
that she's walking up the stairs or
something and she sees that you know how
people have like family pictures and
[__] like all like hung up on the wall
like going up the staircase all of them
were upside down
uh which she thought was very weird
now she just thought it was the
daughters kind of [__] around
um because she walked up and she's like
where the [__] are all these pictures
upside down and then one of the
um bedroom doors like on the upstairs
like kind of closed by itself like I
said she didn't think ghosts first you
wouldn't jump to ghosts first thing I
mean especially if you have teenagers in
the house you'd be like oh well they're
just [__] around
even though they said that they weren't
it's like why the [__] would we turn all
the pictures upside down mom come on now
uh so basically two another thing that
she noticed she's like the windows in
Lauren's room were open all the time and
both the girls were like we didn't open
them and she would get like really mad
because it was just kind of and if you
grew up in Florida like you can't leave
the window which is like the air
conditioning is you're air conditioning
the whole neighborhood you know what I
mean because I remember like my grandma
saying [__] like that like if you open
the window your air conditioning the
whole neighborhood so yeah so you're not
really supposed to open the windows of
the air conditioning is on so the bomb
got really mad and was like you know why
are these windows always open and she's
like I don't know we're not opening them
so I guess they were implying that like
the windows open by themselves all the
time so there was that
um even though and it would happen like
even when Lauren wasn't home like when
she was at school or whatever
so
a few months go by I guess like little
[__] like this was just happening this
whole time
and then one night
um the two teenage girls are home by
themselves
and they hear kind of like a thumping
noise from coming from upstairs and then
like footsteps
so even though if I was home by myself
and I heard that upstairs I would
absolutely not go upstairs I'd be going
out the front door and getting in my
[__] car and getting the [__] away
from there because I'm thinking that's a
living person walking around up there
and I'm not going up there and getting
[__] killed but one of the girls is
like I'm gonna go there and check that
out then I'm like okay that's how every
horror movie starts but all right
so she goes up to check
and then she's like she thought the
sound was coming from her parents Ram so
she goes in there but then there's
nothing in there although in the show
they did have to do they couldn't resist
it they had to do the fake jump scare
where it's real creepy and Lauren's in
there being like looking around the room
it doesn't look like there's anything
and then like the sister comes up behind
her hey what's going on you know what I
mean and she was like what the [__] you
know what I mean so it's like that they
have to do that I guess because nothing
was up there so they had to have some
kind of like scary thing happen so yeah
they did a fake jump scare there
so a few nights after that
uh Jennifer the mom is in the kitchen
and she said
I wish she was like washing the dishes
or whatever and she said she sensed a
change in the air like it just felt the
start started feeling really heavy or
like someone was watching her
and then she looked up there's like a
window over the kitchen sink and she
sees this real creepy face like looking
at it or like a man's face but
the way that she talked um I'm pretty
sure that she didn't think it was a
living person
she said it looked like a face of sheer
evil quote unquote I think that's what
she said and in and actually in the show
like in the reenactment I really like
the makeup job they did on that that was
like real creepy looking like what they
did with the guy like looking at the
window it looked really good because he
had kind of like
his face was like kind of dark kind of
[__] up looking and then like he had
it looked like he had one white eye it
was just like all white
and then the other one like you couldn't
really see it so yeah it was like really
creepy so she saw that and screamed her
[__] head off as as you probably
would
So Jamie her fiance hears her screaming
her head off and runs that she was like
there's somebody out the window she
didn't say it was a ghost or nothing but
she said she said there was somebody
outside the window looking at her So
Jamie goes out there with a bat or
whatever
and uh he's looking around and obviously
there's nobody out there now so instead
of just saying oh well maybe there was
somebody but now they're gone or they
ran away he says basically you're making
it up or you're like imagining it what
he actually said to her was you're
watching too much TV
do you watch too much TV he says to a
grown woman and it's making you see
things outside the window so yeah
and um I I don't know I kind of got the
implication that she was saying that she
thought it was maybe not a person like
maybe she thought it was a ghost because
he I think that at that point that was
when he said oh I think you're watching
too much TV if you think the shit's
haunted or whatever
so Jen decides that even though she's
pretty sure that she just saw a [__]
evil ghost outside the window staring at
her she's like she decided not to tell
her daughters because she didn't want to
scare them or like upset them but after
a while she did actually tell them at
which point they told her that they had
been seeing and hearing [__] too so now
they're kind of all on the same page
they said over the next few weeks
um just they said the fear just kept
getting worse and worse in the house
because they were all you know the three
women were kind of like talking about
the haunting and so they were kind of
like freaking out about it and of course
Jamie like didn't believe any of it and
just thought they were all nuts or
whatever
so um Lauren the older girl she was 18
like I said
um the windows in her room kept opening
by themselves and she's in her room one
night and the closet door opened by
itself
and again
this haven't they seen any more any any
horror movies so she's in the room the
closet door opens by itself what does
she do I mean what would I do I would
run the [__] out of the bedroom and be
like nope I'm not staying in there
anymore she goes toward the closet like
I'm gonna check that out I'm like oh my
God why why are you doing that
so um as if to Punisher for doing this
uh she said she got a real Eerie feeling
and then this big scary shadow man dude
comes like popping out the closet and
he's like reaching for like brah like a
[__] monster you know what I mean
yeah
and so she's like laying on the bed and
she said that she was like paralyzed
like she could she was trying to scream
and she couldn't and like she couldn't
move and all this other kind of [__]
like for a little while and she's like
this thing was just kind of like right
there like hovering over her so finally
though this whatever spell this thing
had over like released her and she
started like yelling her head off like
holy [__] you know what I mean
so then at that point like her mom comes
up and is like what the you know what's
going on up here
and they look at her arm and her arm has
two fresh uh claw marks on it not three
so I like that they didn't do the
Demonic thing because they always
[__] do that it's always three and so
then they bring the priest in and
they're like oh that means it's a demon
this time it was just two it was just
two kind of claw marks and they were
bleeding and stuff now Lauren who was
interviewed on the show
she said that she had seen the man that
the shadow figure and that she saw him
lunge at her but she did not remember
being scratched like she didn't feel
that happen I guess so like this she
just saw that like afterward
so after that
um she's like yeah I don't think I'm
gonna be like staying in this bedroom
anymore and who can blame her really
um and at this point like Jamie is just
he doesn't know what to think he doesn't
know she did that to herself or what the
[__] is going on
so Jennifer decides she's gonna let both
of the girls you know sleep in the room
with them because she's afraid they
might be in danger because now they're
getting hurt and stuff
so she also starts kind of reading Jamie
the riot act about the haunting it's
like you know do you believe us now and
it's like this [__] happened and all
this other kind of stuff and he doesn't
really like a lot of the dudes on a
haunting you know if they can't punch it
they don't really know what to do about
it and one of the dudes on there said
pretty much that exact thing and that
made me laugh because it seemed like
um a lot of dudes were could kind of say
a similar thing but I like that he just
kind of came out and said it like that
like I can't punch it like I don't know
what to do I'm out of options
um but yeah so he clearly didn't know
what to do because this thing is like
[__] up his stepchildren and he's
like can't do anything about it
so and then there's actually we'll get
into this but there's like kind of a
funny uh
It's Kind of a Funny like uh incident
like later on where where that kind of
comes into play
so since he doesn't know what to do
Jennifer's like well I'm gonna find
somebody
uh that can help us
so she calls up this paranormal expert
supposedly in an empath named Tony
Talley who was also extensively
interviewed on the show
so Tony Talley shows up and immediately
says uh the property like even around
the property before you go in the house
feels very negative energy like very
uncomfortable just feels very off
um and she said when you're in the house
you always felt like you had to look
over your shoulder like there was
somebody behind you all the time
so Tony goes up to Lauren's room first
and senses some evil up there as you do
and then apparently she said the mirror
over the dresser in Lauren's room like
fogged up by itself
and then some like some unseen finger
wrote how on there at which point I said
oh my God their house is haunted by the
computer from 2001 A Space Odyssey that
is scary but um but yeah so it wrote Hal
on the mirror so it's like hey that's
where my name is I guess
and then she sees like a dude like the
same kind of the same dude that popped
out of the shed it wasn't really a dude
it was like a Smoky figure person Shadow
thing you know it'll kind of looked like
that so like a dude but like made of
black smoke their effect was actually
pretty good yeah like I said I really
liked the makeup and the effects of this
they were really good they were like
really creepy make a good Standalone
little monster horror movie yeah ghost
story yeah yeah kind of like some out of
The Conjuring yeah kind of like that I
wonder if you would like The Conjuring
movies I've seen some of them I liked
them did you see the one that was based
on Enfield
no
they um saw the one they changed quite a
bit he saw I saw it was but it was still
okay La Llorona La Llorona yeah yeah
that was a good one
that [__] scared the [__] out of that
[__] Hispanic kid that was looking
behind us that's right we saw that in
the theater yeah he was trying to play
it off he screamed like a girl he did
yeah and he goes no I'm just kidding I'm
just kidding and his friends are like
yeah yeah right right yeah right you
were just yeah right well that's okay
that's what horror movies are supposed
to do
high-pitched scream like a girl
that's awesome though
I mean I didn't think I didn't think
that movie was particularly scary it was
pretty cool I liked the I like the way
it looked yeah yeah I like the way the
screen when he saw it it was coming
close at it remembering that there was
like a flash or something he screamed
that's like super funny that was a
pretty good one yeah it was pretty good
it was what other Conjuring ones do we
see we saw the nun which was that right
yeah it was okay I saw that one and then
um what if you can buy them as a set you
can yeah you can yeah yeah there's a
whole box of all the conjuring movies no
I don't well the thing is that I know
like a lot of people really like or
especially like the first Conjuring
movie
um but
it's good but it's not like great like I
get why people like it I'm not like a
big I don't know it doesn't stand out as
much to me as it seems to stand out to
other people maybe that's just me okay
well if anybody wants us to review the
entire Conjuring
series I mean The Conjuring Universe how
many movies is it now seven I don't know
but seven eight if anybody wants us to
get on that if you send us the box set
on Blu-ray we'll do it Twitter I'm
pretty sure there's like a whole box we
still gotta finish [__]
um the uh the base Motel I gotta finish
Bates Motel
but have you been reviewing That season
by season no I still got to do season
one that's like that's next on my agenda
I'm hoping to get to it in like a week
or two yeah okay I forgot was that Tammy
that said that who sent that Celtic
angel said yeah yeah that's right Celtic
Angel said that right so we got to get
that done too yeah because I've watched
I watched the first season I've seen
part and part of the second one I
couldn't really get into it but I'll try
again on the second season yeah well if
you want to re-watch the first season
with me we can do that too no I'm good
let's get through it all right we'll get
through
because I was gonna like kind of scroll
through it like again so I could so you
can remember so I could write a script
about it okay well how long would that
take to go through the whole season
again I don't know I don't remember how
many episodes it is but okay I mean you
know we can we can get to it like over
the next couple days
um yeah so
so the woman uh the Paranormal lady sees
the you know Hal written on the mirror
and sees the Smoky dude in the corner
and she uh you know I wrote Tony drops
her nuts
um yelling you're not welcome here the
Holy Spirit that's welcome is God and
bloody blah
and uh that seems to work temporarily
the ghost is like okay fair enough and
like you know vanishes
so at that point Tony is drawn to the
backyard
and says it feels real [__] creepy
back there saying like um she senses
that a lot of lives have been lost on
this property sensing extreme sadness
and says that she sees a vision of many
people hanging from the trees which was
also like a pretty effective image they
didn't show
they mostly just it was It was kind of
good they kind of showed like people
hang but like just mostly like their
feet and so they're all like dangling
from trees and stuff which I thought was
kind of like a creepy image
so apparently what she takes from this
like from her Visions is that Hal the
dude that wrote on the mirror and the
[__] that's haunting the house was a
slave trader like a plantation slave
master because I guess this area used to
be a plantation
like I said it's right on Escambia Bay
and there's a lot of slave trade going
on there
so apparently this dude was
um you know a real dick and uh
apparently mistreated slaves like killed
them [__] like that
so because she surmises that it's Hal
that's haunting this house she assumes
that the family is probably in danger
so she goes and tells the family what's
going on and says uh the dude I saw in
my vision who I'm presuming is how uh is
this real tall dude big guy bald
um you know with this horrible scowl on
his face it was like she describes him
and uh Jennifer and the teenage
daughters are like holy [__] that's the
dude that we've seen around the house so
you know confirmation there I'm guessing
so they're like okay well what else you
gonna do you gotta do a cleansing that's
what you gotta do
um so Tony starts in Lauren's room and
does the whole
sage and all that stuff
and then for the next few days this is
what always happens in these shows man
for the next few days everything's okay
hey it feels like pretty good in the
house Everything feels lighter like
maybe the ghost is disappeared no smells
sanctity or nothing like that but let's
not go that far but um you know it feels
like oh maybe the cleansing like got rid
of this dick ghost that they have in the
house
and they're hoping that they can have
their normal lives back right
however uh if you've seen any episode of
the show at all
you always know that this is just the
Calm before the storm because you know
that like shit's gonna get real bad
afterward and it's gonna get worse and
that's exactly what happens the next
thing that happens is this [__] ghost
how
he grabs Jamie's ankle like the guy
grabs him and drags him out of bed right
like
and this part was super funny because
Jamie has not really believed any of
this Supernatural nonsense up until this
point until whoever this ghost was
grabbed his ankle and like hefted him
out the bed right and he thought that
the hand I guess he thought that the
hand had come from like under the bed so
he thought somebody like a person was
under the bed so he jumps out of the bed
and like [__] and he said something
that's not exactly what he said but I'm
paraphrasing he said something like um
you know I'm a standard Southern
Christian boy or whatever and he's like
and I keep a Bible next to my bed right
next to the 45 and I'm 45 on top of it
on top of it and I was like yeah that
tracks
that's why we laughed because I was like
protection against [__] you know the
Earthly and the honor right it's like we
got it both right there covered right
right within like reaching distance yeah
so it's like you know whatever you need
to so yeah so he had that right there so
he picks up the 45 and he just he's
gonna shoot the bed he's just like
standing there being like come out for
better there [__] you know what
I mean he didn't say that but you know
what I mean so then he like flips the
whole bed over like he flips the
mattress over and he flips the frame
over and everything like that and of
course there's nobody there yeah at
which point he starts freaking out Jen
was laughing at it I wasn't really
laughing at it because I did that I did
something very similar to that in that
in that bad house that I was in
[__] that that one night where that
thing was I felt it [__]
bearing down on me [__] and it was
just
just [__] oppressing me I couldn't
figure out what it was it was like
something just staring at you like it
just [__] hated you like it was
slimming around you I grabbed a weapon
but it was more like a Talisman I knew I
would you couldn't shoot it
but it just made you felt better yeah I
think you know what I mean like that you
know and uh I grabbed it it was a Ruger
GP 137 Magnum revolver stainless
because they all they were only
stainless I think I don't think they
made blue ones
but I just grabbed that and [__] I
started threatening it or get it the
[__] off me yeah this is your house and
I will burn this house down
I will burn your house down if you don't
leave me alone it went away
didn't [__] with me ever again after
that not directly
but the presence was still in there
never saw it never moved anything
just very disturbing feeling
the place was very strong with the dark
side
not just me girlfriends Eric who who was
the guy my Army buddy we got out
four days apart and moved to Boston
when we ETS
if it was just get out of the army and
then moved in there we moved into that
place
three big old three-story [__]
Victorian house
where the layout didn't make sense I
forgot what the name of the
I forgot what the name of the street was
but I could find it on the map the
little bitty Circle
a little cul-de-sac
and um
right off of in Arlington Massachusetts
that [__] was a little neighborhood one
of the boroughs of Boston there was
something wrong with that house
and he didn't believe in any of that
[__] he knew there was something wrong
with that house
I think well the reason that I laughed
at this particular dude uh
but is one of the reasons is what Zach
just said I remember this one the acting
from the dad in this episode is so bad
yeah I think that was part of it and I
also thought it was amusing I always
think it's amusing in these shows
because the dudes are always just like
you you girls are crazy like you see and
all this other kind of stuff and then
like something like that happens and I
just love the way like his poor like
wife and kids have been dealing with
this for months and months and he's just
like been poo-pooing the whole thing and
then all of a sudden like he and then he
just flips his [__] [__] and it's
like and they're just like
told you so like you know uh so I so for
some reason that's very very funny to me
so it's like so the fact that he and I
was laughing to it like the whole like
Bible with the 45 it was like that made
me laugh too you can't punch it that's
what I'm saying you can't find [__] and
so they don't and so like I said they're
out of options the only thing that you
can do they were out of options I just
felt hostage what it what it valued
which was the house
I held that hostage I said I'm gonna go
outside and I'm gonna get some gasoline
out of the car and burn his house down
and [__] it
and I meant it and it went away well it
got off of me it's trying to drive me
out of the house
trying to drive Eric out of the house
too
so you never saw it never moved so you
knew what it's weakness yeah his
weakness was the house it wanted it
wanted the house wanted to stay in the
house like yeah
so nobody ever really seems to think to
do that on a haunting do they they
always kind of threaten the ghosts are
just like man what the [__] are you
gonna you're always threaten what the
enemy values most
well yeah but I'm just saying it's you'd
think that somebody on a hunting would
have thought of that
it's not
it's not it's like it's not my house
I'll give a [__]
you know not my problem it's not my
[__] problem all right [__] you know
I don't know what happened I was it got
cold in there I had it I had a lamp it
shorted out shorted out yeah yeah no no
what happened
but yeah so I did laugh at the guy
because the guy goes on at least big
long tirade everybody's like this is my
house this is but he's just like wigging
out and like I said Zach is like he's
not the best actor but that made it like
way funnier to me just the fact that he
was standing over their point in the 45
like the Bachelor's of the frame that he
had like flipped over because he thought
something was under there and something
that grabbed his ankle and so he's just
like standing there like yelling at
nobody and it's just like I don't know
that really made me laugh a lot but yeah
so he just goes on this big love [__]
thing
so at this point Jennifer calls Tony
back the Paranormal expert and says um
the [__] came back so
implication being that your cleansing
didn't work so maybe you might need to
like come back and help out and maybe
fix that
so Tony to her credit does actually come
back to the house and does the second
cleansing which what the [__] else are
you gonna do I mean it's not like you
can
that's all they can do they just do a
cleansing you do a cleansing or are you
doing exorcism and then they're like
well I'm out of ideas there's like
really nothing else you can do
um so at this point she does the second
cleansing and she's like look um
this is like uh this is gonna need some
divine intervention probably it's like
so I don't really know if I can handle
this by myself and she's kind of like
afraid for the family especially now
that this [__] goes to is like you
know not only Claude the daughters but
also you know grab the dude's ankle and
pulled him out of bed and [__] like that
so he's clearly like very powerful and
very pissed off uh evidently
so while Tony is there doing the
cleansing or whatever apparently there's
like a like a real loud thumping noise
like on the wall behind her and then
they said
it looked like she's spaced out and then
she gets like bodily thrown back against
the wall you know what I mean uh so yeah
which was also kind of funny way more
eyes than that uh sure yeah I'm gonna
make myself another drink oh okay wow
that was quick yeah take care
[Laughter]
taking care of business that business
being getting inebraded but uh but yeah
so she gets thrown back against the wall
in what is actually like kind of a funny
I don't know because she was just like
this this dumpy older lady and it was
just like what if you were really
getting throwback against the wall
um and on her arm like after they she's
recovered and everything they go over
and get her
and they said on her arm it looked like
something bit her and like it was like a
flame it looked kind of like I mean in
the reenactment it kind of looked like a
vampire bite to be honest it was just
kind of like two Fang marks with like
blood coming out or something
uh and at this point Tony is like yeah
um this is beyond my pay grade clearly
um so I'm just gonna get the [__] out if
you don't mind uh like I said you can't
blame her and she's like but I will find
somebody to help you whether she
actually did or not I don't know because
what happened after that
is that the family is like you know this
is getting bad and maybe we should move
uh you know even though just like most
families on this show like you know not
everybody can just like [__]
oh I forgot what I said
is it back the same as it was before
I guess I was sitting there thinking wow
that ice melted really fast like just
from this from the next room over but it
is Florida so you know ice doesn't last
too long
um but yeah so so they're talking about
moving and they're like well we can't
really afford it and blah blah
but maybe we should and all that
and then there's a scene where Lauren
the 18 year old is thank you is in her
mom's closet like a walk-in closet like
just kind of like [__] around she's
like trying on her clothes and hats and
crap like that like you do
and she sees
see I don't know if she saw this did she
say that she saw the ghost behind her
like in the mirror
like it was kind of over there like it
was one white eye like we're looking
like tour Johnson I can't remember time
for her to go to bed you know how they
are they do tricky [__] they do yeah she
says one thing and then they show you
something but she didn't actually say
that she saw that because sometimes they
just show it like behind them and I'm
like yeah and that's just kind of one of
the tricks that this series does you're
not quite sure if they added that fact
if they added that scene or if she said
she saw that I don't know
they do that yeah but so evidently so
like the ghost is kind of like lurking
around back there in the back of the
closet and then she said that she felt
like a burning or stinging sensation
like on the back of her neck and then
she screams and then the mom comes in
and there's like a big
uh scratch like down she said it was
from the bottom of her hairline like all
the way like down to the middle of her
back like not super deep or anything
like that but I guess it was like deep
enough to draw blood evidently at least
according to what they said
so this is apparently the last straw for
Jennifer
um she is like we are leaving this
[__] house right now I don't really
give a [__] about the financial
situation or anything like that I just
can't take it anymore
um and at this point I guess Jamie the
husband you know since he had some bad
[__] happened to him too
um he conceded and he was actually like
interviewed on the show too he's like I
had to concede that the house won uh
because you know we just couldn't stay
there anymore
so they did actually end up uh
struggling financially for a while
um you know but eventually they got
their [__] back together they did
mention at the end of this show that the
million dollar house which like I said
they mentioned that several times that's
how much it was uh it got sold back to
the bank so I guess it got foreclosed on
and eventually ended up selling to
someone else for a hundred and nineteen
thousand dollars which is very cheap uh
for a house of that presumed size which
you know if it was a million dollars
so there's that so evidently they moved
away and didn't have any more issues I
don't know uh they didn't mention if the
next person that owned the house had any
uh trouble with the same [__] ghost
uh pulling them out of bed or whatever
Tony the Paranormal expert
um whether this had anything to do with
this case or not but they just they
thought it would they would mention it
uh she said that she was sick for many
years after this uh case and actually
stopped doing paranormal stuff for a
while uh one of the things that I think
they ended up she didn't she say they
removed like a four pound tumor or
something like that so I don't know if
that had anything to do with any I'm
sure that was probably just a
coincidence but she attributed her years
of bad Health afterward to this
particular
house or this particular case and she
said she even stopped doing paranormal
[__] for a while because of the trauma
so there's that but like I said that was
pretty much
it they didn't really say if they had
any other problems like I said when they
moved to another house or if anybody
else moved to this house and had
problems or and like I said I don't know
where exactly this house is so I don't
know if it's like famous for being
particularly haunted or anything like
that but like I said I did like this one
because it didn't have there was no
demon [__] because I mentioned exorcism
it wasn't an exorcism there was no
church involved or nothing like that and
I I think you were in the bathroom when
I mentioned it but I said I like that
they I mean they had like the the cuts
on the arms like the scratches on the
arms but it was just two like they
didn't do the three three like that was
all demonstrated and then it's like you
know oh that's it's a it's a mockery of
the Trinity that's what they always say
that's why there's three of them and I'm
just so I'm just kind of like well I
like that they just kind of kept it
simple like it's just a ghost and it's
just a jerk and it won we gotta had to
get the [__] out of there yeah so they
didn't solve it like they just had like
a cleansing and then the ghost was like
[__] all y'all I'm yeah
and I was kind of the under the
impression that this that this story
actually was a little more credible than
some of the other stories in this in in
the series
because it was kind of a little bit
atypical
and it was more along the lines of like
[__] that I have actually personally
seen you never really get down to the
bottom of it
yeah you know uh and this [__] about
you're gonna exercise it in the church
everything that's that's more like an
invention a daytime talk show usually
because back in the 80s watching Geraldo
and Jesse Raphael and [__] they really
wouldn't do a show on on the on a
haunted house unless
some pseudo-clergyman wasn't there
yeah you know or the Warrens
which the warrants were mostly full of
[__] mostly they were on some real cases
like the anfield but they got kicked off
at anfield well they just showed up
nobody asked him to come there right
which is what I thought was funny that
they made a Conjuring movie which like I
said if you don't you know they made
um with the Warrens in it that was um
yeah
about Enfield and they had them as the
main characters right it's not true they
got kicked off that case they were only
there one they said they showed up on
the doorstep like nobody called them or
nothing like that they just showed up
and was like Hey we're here to
investigate a case and they're like who
the [__] are you yeah and they were and
they were there only for a few hours and
they basically got kicked out of there
yeah so
because they're like it's okay yeah The
Conjuring movie about the Enfield is
pretty uh
[__] now they did have Morris gross
the character that played Morris gross
but he was kinda
kinda uh
misrepresented a bit
um in the movie from what I remember and
there was no mention of guy Playfair
well guy Playfair was in there too and
he wrote the book I think what you're
thinking because I don't think you've
seen The Conjuring movie that was based
on Enfield because that was like totally
different because I saw one that was it
okay they did do
um for British TV they did do a three
episode mini series that was made and it
was actually pretty good yeah although
like it's it it hewed pretty close to
the story like for the first two
episodes but then the third one they
kind of went crazy with it okay you know
what I mean I saw so yeah we might have
watched that together because I remember
like writing about it in The Conjuring
one the warrants are the main characters
yeah well because that's kind of the
whole okay thing okay well then I
haven't seen those then right
um or I think maybe I've seen clips from
it
but I don't think I've seen those
because the warrants weren't really
involved in the anfield case no they
weren't um
oh Annabelle that was another one that
we saw did we see one of the Annabelle
movies yeah
yeah that was all right
we didn't see the first Annabelle in the
theater we saw Annabelle
something I don't remember what the
second one was but we saw that one in
the theater the wars were
a marvelous couple
when it came to
grifting off of the Paranormal
they were demonologists they were they
were they were a creation of their era
they were charlatans though yeah big
time we've done a couple shows yeah even
though I think some of the cases that
they were on were real
but they were they were bullshitters
yeah they just like they like to show up
and insert themselves yeah into
investigations so they could write books
and then go on the talk show circus
right and say that it's like oh we've we
figured this case out or we solved it or
whatever yeah Sebastian said I thought
it was uh Maurice gross's case yeah it
was yeah it was more gross most gross
and it was being documented by Guy lion
play fair yeah he was an author yeah and
his book is called uh this house is
haunted and we have it here hardcover
it's a I had to buy it used off of eBay
it got it didn't it was cheap it wasn't
cheap it was expensive it was an old
library old library book and it's a
great book and
um if you read this house is haunted guy
lion play fair
and read Mammoth Mountain Poltergeist
that was about the story of me Lois and
red and the Poltergeist that Poltergeist
incident that happened with us and it
only lasted like a week okay they
usually don't last long
you'll see that
Enfield was a lot more powerful it
lasted a lot longer it had some badass
phenomenon but in general my ours was
like that
it's recurrent spontaneous psychokinesis
and it has and it's 13 14 year old kids
emanated and created through the
subconscious mind
at the time I thought it was Ghost we
all thought it was a ghost but looking
back on it no because it's happened
since then it's happened recently
I can get it to do a few little things
here and then but I have to be
frustrated or angry mostly frustration
because agar you can vent anger
frustration is you can't vent it so it
it vents out in
recurrent spontaneous psychokinesis
but it's not your conscious mind
it's one of your unconscious
personas that does it like a character
out of one of your dreams
Sebastian says I can imagine Tom and
Jenny's version of a house cleansing Tom
pulls out a Magnum 357 and threatens to
burn it out and Jenny shouts [__] bad
ghost leaves quick yeah yeah we're not
going to do any of that hippy dippy like
no I was glad they [__] with the
city
turn this damn house down if I see you
again it's not my house it's your house
and I'm gonna burn it
that's what I told her I know this is
your house that's why I'm gonna burn it
if you [__] with me
and then what are you going to do you're
just going to be a ghost standing in a
field like a douche I said I'll just get
in the car and leave
okay he's like I can go to the Holiday
Inn [__]
it didn't [__] with us
we were only there another six months
after that
they did cut I could tell it was in
there though
our girlfriends [__] could tell it
was there
you had to escort him to the bathroom
and wait outside while they peed they
didn't want to walk down the hallways by
themselves
it was a creepy house it was a bad house
it's just funny to me to think that like
the ghost if you did burn the house down
and then the ghosts would just be
standing there like a dick like in the
middle of this in the middle of a lot
three-dimensional space it's like it's
like somehow yeah he's like wow somehow
like being a ghost isn't quite as scary
like if you don't have like a haunted
house you know what I mean I'm just kind
of standing here in an empty lot that's
not quite as yeah it's not quite as
creepy yeah looking at the houses on
either side [__] with forlorns
we're in my house maybe I could go hop
that house well maybe that's like we'll
see I don't know how the rules work it's
like no you can only haunt that house
and that house is gone now so you have
to stay in this empty lot like forever
yeah or maybe it works like Beetlejuice
where you just have to be there for like
125 years or something and you can't
leave because then the sand worms will
get you yeah
they're kind of a Beetlejuice too is
coming out
I saw the um Dune two is coming out
that's right that was the other that was
the other preview that we saw yeah it
looks good yeah we're gonna do in one
gotta see that again yeah it's on
um I think it's on Hulu or uh Amazon
Prime or something I read the book I
read the book a couple times I read it a
long time ago it's pretty close the
teenager yeah it's pretty close well I
mean it's a lot closer than the David
Lynch one yeah
I do too but it's like I can see why he
wanted his name taken off that one that
was it wasn't like you know David Lynch
usually does his own [__] yeah so that
was just like adapting someone else's
the look of the Lynch movie is really
good yeah yeah yeah it looks really good
and I mean he was real
um hamstrung by
so it's like he couldn't really do what
he wanted to do and I think that kind of
like soured him on that whole experience
he's like [__] it I'm just gonna make my
own [__] movies from now on and I
can't blame him they made toys for that
movie
which is [__] big serious collector's
items if you have them new in the boxes
I remember when they came out I should
have gotten some when I was a kid
they're the sad crawler and they had all
the thing is they they just weren't as
cool toys as as star Star Wars toys well
and the thing about Dune is that it's
not not really aimed at children
so it's like it seemed like an odd
choice but I mean they were trying to do
toys for every [__] man back in the 80s
people [__] about nowadays but back in
the 80s they had like even a movie you
wouldn't even think was like anything
like they would have like [__] toys
and board games and [__] like that like
based around this [__] movie which
you know what I mean so yeah
uh let's see Ben says I'm in a dune
Facebook discussion group and it's
mostly people making fun of the Lynch
movie fans
I can imagine I
don't David Lynch is probably my
favorite director
um but I mean that dude maybe it's it
looks cool as hell I'm gonna say that
and I have watched it several times and
I've read the book so I kind of know
what's going on but it's like it's still
it just doesn't make a lot of sense but
like I said I don't know it seemed like
he was mostly that that wasn't really
his fault it seemed like you know there
was a lot of Studio interference and
stuff and he was just kind of like [__]
this that's like why he didn't he I
think he pulled an Alan Smithy on it
didn't he
at least until he got his own cut but I
don't know I I think it's cool looking
but I really really liked the new one
the Denny Villeneuve one and uh the
second one looks like kick ass so but
like I said I really do have to watch
because we saw the first one in the
theater
but um I'm gonna have to watch it again
to I remember what happened but
I just saw it when we were scrolling
through
Amazon Prime or whatever last night I
said oh we should probably watch that
before we go see the new one at the
theater but I don't remember when it
comes out I think we were talking and we
didn't see the date I do remember that
the last Voyage of the Demeter is
starting in
mid-august it was either August 10th or
August 15th I can't remember
Ben says I honestly prefer the Sci-Fi
mini-series
but yeah but people mock them almost as
much as Lynch the problem with the mini
series I remembered it uh was the uh the
costumes were just [__] some of the
acting was [__] terrible
the the David Lynch movie had had the
had the great look though the the way it
looked and the costumes and everything
was good just that
the Dune book is unmovieable in as a
standalone movie it's got to be multiple
parts
and Tino de laurentis didn't want that
he wanted that studio thought they could
only afford yeah it's like let's just
cram it all in a friend movie which is
impossible yeah
you can't do it so they then they wanted
something to rival Star Wars well Star
Wars was a trilogy
yeah so why didn't they just go that
route but that they didn't think that
David had the money but it was kind of a
dealer rental Studios a man they had
some really good movies Conan one and
everything and they had some real
masterpieces
I really liked Flash Gordon even though
I think that kind of bombed at the
theater but it's iconic you know if I
can seeing it on HBO back in the day and
VHS I still love that movie
um but
and it is what it is you know what I
mean it's it's that slash Gordon that's
the way that's the way the source
material was
but um
I forgot where I was going with this
it's just that
Dune had to be done they were dumb they
should have committed to like at least
two movies with dude they wouldn't do
that back then though it was like it's
like nowadays you know they'll be like
yeah we're gonna do like a whole you
know we're gonna do a Trilogy or we're
gonna do a whole series of these movies
like they kind of yeah plan it more yeah
you know because everything has to be
like a a universe nowadays right because
it's like they want to cash in on the
[__] yeah but back then they didn't
really do that it's like they're like
well the movie came out it did really
well it was somebody quick like let's
Cobble together a [__] Sequel and it
didn't like you know had had DiLaurentis
Studios said okay we're gonna agree to
two movies
let's cut the story in half
Lynch would have [__] delivered I
think a really good first half and it
made a lot of money which would have
Justified the sequel I mean and this is
how stupid
I don't want to say stupid
excited T laurenti Studios was [__]
had moments of [__] Brilliance and
then just moments of bone-headedness
every time they did something good they
counteracted it with something
bone-headed
a good example was Conan the Barbarian
Conan one John millius that movie is a
[__] Masterpiece that stands to to
today and some of the more modern edits
of it that have the the director's Cuts
they have a lot of [__] that was taken
out put back into it that movie is
mythological as hell and it's it's it's
very [__] Friedrich Nietzsche lessons
and [__]
that movie was [__] great and the
outro promised part two
and had they made that part too
but with millius they would have [__]
had a an epic on their hands but they
said you know what we probably missed uh
part one was a hit but it was rated R we
probably could have made a lot more
money if it was [__] PG yeah let's
make it a kids movie right and then they
just [__] shot them and how'd that go
let's show that rated R
with more violence actually more sex and
more violence and more [__]
mythological [__] in there and they
should have gone for their [__] adult
market and they would have made a lot of
money because the first one was a hit it
made a lot of money
they thought they could make more if
they made a PG it's not it's exactly the
opposite happened
Destroyer came out
the store's got a lot of problems man
stupid [__] boss fight monsters that
just look terrible I will give it to
give it the that Conan the Destroyer is
closer to the Marvel Comics of the time
yeah
but that's not really what they should
have done
and yeah milius's version of Conan the
Barbarian is not really close to the
[__]
powered books but it was its own
creation it was it was basically Star
Wars prehistoric Star Wars you know it
was good real good they should have just
gone with that it would have been great
because Milius already had I think he
had two other movies yeah they could
have done a whole trilogy yeah he had
two other movies planned
it was how to be a man when you're young
how to be a man in middle age how to be
a man when you're old how do you stay
relevant that was the [__] it was a
trilogy yeah it's tailor-made for for
that yeah for a Trilogy yep that had
been awesome yeah that's what it was
supposed to be but it's like too late
now obviously because well I mean they
can't do it with Schwarzenegger
obviously because he's old now but
yeah if
they'll never get the money and it
couldn't be Hollywood it would have to
be
the Robert E Howard estate owns
everything Conan and they are protecting
it like crazy they will not let that
property go into the hands of anybody
but a [__]
true Conan fan it's got to stay true to
to Howard's Vision because they're like
a reli it's owned by almost by a
religious group right now they won't let
hack filmmakers
touch it which that's great
it's better now yeah they're trying yeah
it's better not to have any Conan than
having a shitty one right right because
they have bad Conan that last Conan even
though that last Conan could have been
good it wasn't
with that guy what's that Momoa Jason
Momoa oh yeah yeah I thought he made a
good Conan but just a storytelling
sucked that was not yeah I mean he
definitely has the look for yeah
who really could do it now as [__] um
Pena I think his name is Joseph or
Robert Pena and that's that's Arnold
Schwarzenegger's son
yeah yeah uh his illegitimate son he's
uh who he had with the Mexican maid it
looks just like our own and he's he's a
bodybuilder he could easily play Conan
yeah yeah Joseph Pena is his name
I don't know if you can act I don't well
but he looks just like his dad I don't
know if I've ever seen him actually he's
a good looking kid he's about as big as
Arnold was and he claims to be natural
that he's not on any gear they might be
what they all say though he might be
yeah he's not quite as big as his dad
you know yeah but uh his dad had good
genetics
he might be on it test
but he's in his 20s still
but the thing I mean the thing about it
that I think is better about
entertainment nowadays is that at least
they're willing now to take like a big
book or an intellectual property or
something like that and they'll say you
know this is too much for one movie so
we're gonna make a Trilogy or we're
gonna make a series you know it's not
they're not trying to cram everything
into one movie they still do it every
now and then because Tammy brought up
Dark Tower which yeah that of all things
that was a really stupid thing to try to
cram into one movie terrible how many
[__] books are in the Dark Tower
series terrible a lot so you know trying
to do that I mean it would have been
good if they'd have just like done the
first book you know and then the two the
first book is too hard to put in them
well that's what I mean well yeah but
they could have done like part one and
then seeing how that went that first
book could could cover three movies
easily you know what we we're talking
about
um
the what what's the Stephen King book
that you liked a lot about the um
[__] man the Talisman The Talisman there
yeah
yeah and uh there was a sequel to that
too I think it was called the black
house but I never did read that but um
that's one that they never have adapted
and I don't think that they've ever even
talked about adapting that but that
actually might be
a decent
like I said I I read the Talisman but I
hadn't read the black house which is a
sequel but that might be a good they
don't adapt a lot of Peter Straub stuff
unfortunately
um I can't really I mean they did ghost
story that was back in the 80s and then
they did uh The Haunting of Julia yeah
um with Mia Farrow that was based on his
novel Julia and then
um
was that it
I don't know just put the Talisman and
um
the Gunslinger would have made great
miniseries yeah we've been better than
movies it should have been something
along the lines of like uh what's it
what's that like um
uh what's the one with the uh the Retro
series uh
strange stranger things stranger things
which you still haven't watched I
haven't seen it but it'd be like
stranger things
you know that's you could probably get
three seasons out of uh
out of [__] um the talisman
that's the way I was yeah
and you could probably get two or three
seasons out of the [__] The Dark
Tower or the Gunslinger could have
gotten probably three seasons easily
because a lot happens in that book
and I think that would actually probably
be really successful if it was done well
it was done right the tone was correct
Dark Tower has got to be over
otherworldly because that's happening in
a parallel dimension
yeah
I was trying to put half of the Talisman
is happening in a parallel universe yeah
I was trying to I was kind of thinking
about it again last night because we
re-watched last night we were just like
flipping through like looking for some
[__] to watch and we ended up
re-watching room 237
the documentary about shining conspiracy
theories
it's fun to watch it was fun to watch
yeah even though I most of the [__] in
there is a reach I'm not saying that
Kubrick didn't
didn't put like some layers and [__]
like that in there because there is
definitely like some hidden meaning and
whatnot but I think some of the stuff in
there you know they have the guy that's
you know said that he helped fake the
moon landing and all that other kind of
stuff but um you know the stuff about
the genocide of the Native Americans and
stuff like that I think that's legit but
some of the other stuff about the Apollo
and all that other kind of stuff I think
that's a bunch of crap
yeah but um
I don't know but I never get tired of
hearing about like shining conspiracy
theories I don't know why it's like so
because I love that maybe and it's just
like fascinating to me
but that's a good documentary it's on 2B
actually yeah Kubrick was a great
director he's he's a genius and because
of that if he makes a mysterious movie
you're going to have people try to read
in to every little [__] asset yeah he
wasn't that [__] to the details he did
it there is a lot of detail in there a
lot of stuff about the Native Americans
I believe was
yeah I mean because that was pretty
overt pretty over my take on it is
different though
they were saying well this has to do
with the Native American genocides
that's I don't believe that that's what
uh Kubrick was talking about
he says it's established in the story
that when they were building the
Overlook they had to repel a couple of
Indian attacks it's and and then what's
his name Tallman
what was that guy's name
Omen says this supposedly is built on an
Indian burial ground he says supposedly
not we know it's on the Indian basis
supposedly
I think what I think what
um Kubrick is talking about
is that the Indians were trying to get
the white man off of cursed land
not necessarily blessed land but cursed
land that makes more sense that this was
an evil place
and they were building on top of it and
going to disturb it
which would have been dangerous for
everybody on that land yes they're like
hey knock it off yeah don't do don't put
it there that's just radioactive and
also maybe they might have had some kind
of Covenant with the Native American
Gods
to keep people off that land maybe it
would break some kind of agreement they
had with the Gods
and a lot of Indians a lot of Native
Americans people forget this this goes
back to the 1600s 15 1600s
were Christian or part Christian where
they have mixed Christianity with their
own native beliefs
so they might have been trying to save
people get off that [__] land
that's a bad place they built that [__]
on that land and it becomes a temple of
evil these rich people going in there he
Rich evil people going in there doing
bad [__] when they die they're trapped
there now you've got all these pervy
sexually aggressive [__] ghosts
trying to kill get people to kill each
other so they could join the party
literally he says join the party yeah
like feed off their feeding off of
people right
and I believe the reason why the Indians
were
attacking us to keep them off that
[__] cursed land
that makes a lot more sense
because burial grounds were not cursed
lands more like blessed lands that was a
hollowed ground
you could build there
it wouldn't be an evil place
it would just be you're disrespect and
they're dead you know what I mean but uh
be like building on his graveyard but I
think they were trying I think it was
cursed land something was bad there the
place was strong went to dark side
yeah which kind of makes more sense to
me actually yeah and I think the elites
that built that there knew it was bad
that's why they were building there
that's what they wanted that they wanted
that they were trying to build a temple
to evil and then they put a bunch of
Native American stuff in there
okay
to kind of add insult to injury yeah
that type of deal
yeah because that was something and I
don't even remember it's been a couple
years since I reread the book but I
don't think
that wasn't no that angle wasn't
mentioned was it I didn't think it was
that I remembered no it was but in the
book from what I remember it was a
secluded area
where the elites would go and basically
part and and they basically were
partaking in debauchery right and there
was murders and rapes and all kinds of
stuff that was happening there and over
time it built up into its own thing and
then the hotel had its own had its own
spiritual identity that was capturing
ghosts
they're talking about Stephen King
stories yeah good restaurant uh man
again yeah
Camp guys aesthetic app apt people yeah
dedication it the sand My Pretty Pony
King short stories are great
um Camp guy says dedication is the
sickest Stephen King short story I do
not remember that one
what book is that one in because I don't
remember if I read that or not
apps pupil they did make a movie of that
and I remember seeing it and it just
being kind of like mid-tier
see because you know and I've written
about this on my
on my uh blog as well I have I'm like
fascinated by Stephen King adaptations
and there's been a lot of them I mean
he's written a lot of stuff obviously
but it seems like most of them are kind
of like I know that a lot of people like
have a perception that it's like oh
Stephen King adaptations they all suck
stuff like that but they don't
um a lot of them are actually really
good a couple of them are like pretty
[__] terrible but most of them are
just kind of like okay the thing about
Stephen King is that he's written so
much that there's adaptations of his
stuff that I didn't even know existed
until like recently like for okay for
example I accidentally came across this
movie I don't even remember how I came
across it was a couple years ago
and the movie was called mercy and it
had
um the kid that played Carl on Walking
Dead what's that kid's name I can't
remember what his name is
um but he was in it
and it was based on the Stephen King
story grandma do you guys remember that
one I think it was in it wasn't a night
shift I think it was in Skeleton Crew
um
and I was like I didn't even know they
made a [__] movie version they added
a bunch of [__] because like the story
isn't that long but you know like the
last third of the movie is like pretty
much straight up like the short story is
but it's like so that just goes to show
like how much [__] Stephen King has
written that it's like they've made
adaptations of his stuff that I didn't
even know that they adapted it you know
what I mean and it wasn't named the same
thing as the story so I didn't initially
realize that it was based on the Stephen
King story and I'm just like oh holy
[__]
he also does that thing where I guess he
still does this where he has like on his
website he has what he calls
quote-unquote dollar babies and you can
actually buy the rights to he has like a
big list of like his stories and stuff
and you can buy the rights of them for a
dollar and make a movie out of them as
long as you're not he does it for like
student filmmakers you know what I mean
like you can't make a million dollar
movie out of it obviously he's doing it
for people that are learning the craft
and stuff like that so he's like you can
adapt one of my stories for a buck you
know as long as you don't like make a
huge profit I pretty much liked
everything I read of him until I got to
Tommy knockers I didn't like that one I
didn't know anytime I stopped reading
him after that I also did not like dream
catch her most of them most of the books
of his that I've read I I usually like
kind of like them or they're just like
oh they're okay I very rarely have read
one that I actively didn't like I did
not like Tommyknockers I did not like
dream catcher and the movie they made of
that was just hilarious but um really
bad and I didn't like isn't this
interesting I didn't really like the
book of Dr sleep I liked the movie a lot
better yeah a lot of people talk
[__] about doctor sleep Assad and
Saudi Arabia he loves the [__]
shining so much that he's he's afraid to
watch
doctor sleep because he heard that it
sucked no man you want to see the doctor
sleep the director's cut the full long
Edition yeah some of it ends and ends up
happening in the [__] Overlook but
it's handled well I like the uh the
overlooked scenes
didn't you
yeah I thought it was good I thought
they did a good job yeah and honestly I
liked and the dude that played [__]
the ghost of [__]
the dad was a [__] what's his name uh
Jack yeah Jack Torrance is in his Ghost
and the dude that plays him Nails Nails
it
I also liked they got
um Alex Esso to play Wendy and I thought
she was really good well and I just I
mean if you guys watch my uh my flickers
of fear I just talked about her big
breakout role which was in starry eyes
and I like that she was uh that she
played Wendy though because she kind of
looks like her and she kind of has like
all the mannerisms we saw the theatrical
release in the movies and I thought it
was mediocre that was okay
there were certain problems with the
theatrical release but when you see the
director's cut or the full length
version of it it's a lot better it's a
lot better
um because they cut stuff out for time
and when they cut [__] out it kind of
made the little black girl character
just kind of like why is she in this
movie Abra yeah everybody like why I
seen this movie there's not there's
really nothing much whereas in the book
she's a huge character in the movie
she's like in the in the theatrical cut
of the movie she's like not there's not
enough in there to really justify like
half the half the book is about her is
like from her point of view yeah but in
the in in the full length version that
her character makes a lot more sense
yeah
that was the thing about the movie I
didn't like
because she that character I never read
the book that character seemed like it
was just shoehorned in there right like
why why is she in there they don't
really need that character she's just in
there but like I said she's like a major
yeah yeah in the book she's like a major
character yeah yeah it seemed like with
the movie they were trying to make it
more like oh this is going to be a
sequel to the movie The Shining so they
wanted to have more of that going on
whereas like I said if you read the book
it's probably like half Danny and half
Abra right so and in the full length
edit of it it's more if that's the way
the book is I haven't read it then it's
more like the book right the full length
but I liked it and when they go to the
[__] Overlook it didn't disappoint
they actually did do a good job they did
a good job eating that yeah and Overlook
of course is worse than it was when you
saw it last I mean I was worried about
it too because The Shining is like one
of my favorite I mean The Shining and
the thing are like my two favorite
movies of all time
So and I've seen them both probably like
100 times each so I'm always kind of
like worried that it wasn't I got the
Blu-ray of Dr Sleek yeah but it's like
you know it's nothing's gonna be as good
as The Shining I mean that was like
lightning in a bottle but I was like
pleasantly surprised and I read the book
Dr sleep I didn't love the book I didn't
hate it but I was just kind of like
you know what I mean I wasn't super into
it but I actually kind of liked the
movie better but other than that I mean
I don't know and like I said I think I
mentioned that when I read a kind of
more recent-ish
Stephen King book which is called
Revival which I think came out in 2014 I
want to say maybe later
um I [__] loved that because I hadn't
read a lot of his newer stuff on him
because I lost track you know what I
mean because the dude just keeps writing
and writing and writing and I'm like
holy crap dude I have like other books I
gotta read too chill out but it's like I
found that I found it for like five
dollars like in a used bookstore I was
like holy [__] I never heard of this one
because the [__] just keeps writing and
so I read it and I was like wow this is
fantastic like one of his newer books I
really wish they'd make a movie out of
that that'd be great I liked pretty much
everything I read from Stephen King
except Tommy knockers yeah I didn't like
Tommy I didn't like Tommy I didn't read
anything after that really
um
after that I kind of I joined the army
didn't have time to read books anymore
and then um after my head entry I hated
reading [__] uh my eyes kept jumping
around over the page I can do it now
it's just I just don't have the patience
and then I forget
I forget that I'm halfway through a book
something else will distract me but um
like I still haven't finished Billy
Idol's [__] yeah I bought him like
Billy Idol biography like a long time
ago halfway through it and I can't and
we were in books a million the other day
and they actually had Rob Halfords yeah
autobiography yeah and I was like oh man
we should get that yeah I mean I'll read
it even if you don't I want to read it
so anyway
um
the the thing is with Stephen King is
there's like three or four things I
don't I don't like about him all right
one he his dialogue you can re when you
read it in a book it makes sense but if
you can actually imagine somebody
actually talking like that
yeah it works in a book but not in a
movie which like I said that's why if
you're gonna adopt a Stephen King thing
yeah I kind of have to make some tweets
do it but just because of the
differences in the media another thing
about him is that Stephen King suffers
from magical negro syndrome a little bit
yeah and that's something that that's
talked about a lot in like in certain
kinds of literature all right
um which is that's where every black
character in the book is has magical
powers all right and he's not the only
one that does that a lot of writers do
that it's just him he does yeah he's got
that I mean I'll give him a pass on
Halloran from The Shining it's a great
character because I learned that
character many of those characters but
yeah like he did it in The Green Mile
yeah yeah he does the stand yeah he did
it in every one of his yeah he does it a
lot if there's a black like I said he's
not the only one that does they're going
to be psychic they do it to Native
Americans yeah and Native American right
and then another thing is they're
[__] drove me crazy about Stephen
King is that he didn't know [__] about
guns he'd talk about guns but [__] he
doesn't know anything about him
so he describes guns that never existed
describes guns that don't work that way
uh names guns like a Ruger 44 magnum
automatics there's no such thing as that
it would just drive me crazy like what
the [__]
what the [__] that doesn't exist yeah
because he just pulls random things
instead he said that guys were soldiers
were shooting at each other with full
auto recoilless rifles which means he
doesn't know what a recoilless rifle is
you know there were coils rifle is kind
of like a bazooka I mean he's usually
pretty good
asking people like about [__] so I don't
know why he doesn't like or either that
or the person he asked about it doesn't
know what they're talking about either
that was yeah the stand who said that
[__] you know during the pandemic
soldiers were going rogue and fighting
each other in the streets [__]
shooting each other up with [__]
recoilless rifles with full auto fire a
recoilless rifle is a bazooka not a not
an assault rifle
and it's kind of like a bazooka you take
it down
large 40 millimeter or above 90
millimeter [__] looks like a damn
artillery around and you put it into a
hollow tube and you fire it and it's and
then it's equal and opposite reactions
half the explosion goes out the back the
other half the explosion Chucks the
round out the front it's just a way of
lobbing a big
explosive shell out of a man portable
weapon and because it's equal and
opposite reactions and it's an unlocked
breach you can do it you can launch from
those big things without it blowing you
across the [__] Street when it
happens that's what a recoilless rifle
is but they're single shot
yeah they're not machine guns
so he doesn't know what he's talking
about drive you crazy a couple people
have recommended that I watch Stephen
King book club on YouTube I'm gonna have
to look that up
um also Ben says I read elevation a
while ago it was a sequel to thinner
interestingly I just finished reading
elevation a couple of days ago because I
found it at books a million like in the
bargain section I didn't see it so much
as a
sequel to thinner though because thinner
that was about a dude who ran over a
gypsy and they cursed him and he just
started losing weight no matter how much
it was a great book elevation is not
really a horror novel it's kind of more
a drama with like sci-fi elements he
actually dedicated it to Richard
Matheson so I'm assuming that he was
making because it was kind of a similar
setup to uh shrinking man the Richard
Matheson novel where the dude you know
obviously shrank
but uh great book by the way and it was
made into a great movie but it was more
like he was losing weight but he wasn't
looking any smaller if that makes any
sense and there was a thing too like
where he would have like tons of clothes
on with like all these coins and [__]
his pockets and he would get on the
scale but he would always weigh the same
like he always looked the same but he
was like losing weight like the whole
time even though he didn't look like he
was losing weight does that make sense
yeah so it was kind of it was like a
metaphorical
kind of thing
um but yeah but it wasn't a horror novel
and it's actually it says a novel on it
but it's technically a novella I mean
it's pretty short I read it like in one
afternoon like in an hour or something
so so I don't know if I'd call it a
sequel to thinner it's not really the
same thing but he's kind of coming at it
from the same angle it's still like a
weight loss thing but different you know
um
Ben said didn't the guy in elevation
live in the same house as the attorney
from thinner the doctor knew about the
case and discussed it with him not that
I remember [__] I just read that a
couple days ago and you'd think I would
have picked up on that but I couldn't
remember the name of the guy from I
couldn't remember the name of the guy
from thinner so I don't know but you
could be right I will hand it to King
he's an American Legend of horror he's a
legend
he wrote a lot of good modern American
Horror I had to say straw wrote some
good [__] too
I like Peter Straub yeah he wrote some
stuff I mean I really like his novel
Ghost Story the movie is pretty good
that came out in 1981 but the thing
about it I love that movie I'm not
saying that but the novel ghost story is
so much more complicated that I mean
they had to leave
three quarters of that book out Straub
wrote The Watcher too didn't he the
Watchers no that was Dean [__] Dean Coos
that's right yeah I remember I don't
like Dean Koontz he's pretty good I
liked him he sold almost as many books
as king yeah they don't make a lot of
adaptations of his work Coons that's
right um they did make the Watchers
which was okay
um if you haven't seen Odd Thomas uh
with Anton Yelchin
that came out in the
2013 2014 that's actually really good
but most of the adaptations they make of
Dean koontz's stuff were like really not
good and I have read a few of Dean
koontz's novels and I'm just not into
them I just there are two
they're kind of formulaic yeah that was
the word I was gonna say you know when
you're a young guy though that kind of
helps you get through the book yeah yeah
yeah and I remember reading the Watchers
and loving it
you had the dog that was trained as the
Scout and behind it was like a Yeti that
was the monster the yeti would track you
down and kill you it was like a military
weapon that had gotten out I thought it
was pretty cool was it was it the cyborg
too see I don't even run I don't
remember it's been so long since I read
that like I said I think I have a
psychic link between the dog and the
[__] Yeti
wow you think I remember something like
you remember that no yeah well like I
said his books didn't really make that
much of an impression
Army experimental weapon that got out
and it was basically a dog and a Bigfoot
basically it was a psychic link between
the two how do they come up with this
[__] and the dog was kind of like the
Scout it would go out but it was
friendly
and the friendly Bigfoot yeah and then
the Bigfoot could see through the dog's
eyes know when to attack and [__] yeah
it was like the killer module
that's how I remembered it it's been a
long time since I read it right it might
be a little bit different but that's how
I remembered it I don't know it's kind
of like the predator in a way I might
revisit some of the machine one of these
days but I mean like I said he sold like
a bajillion bucks and it's weird that
they don't make as many
um make as many adaptations of his work
as they did oh yeah I was like holy [__]
he's been in the bathroom like [__]
10 times already
yeah the actor from Odd Thomas poor guy
he died horribly yeah he died like in a
freak accident and that is such a good
movie I recommend it to
I wrote about it like I think I did a
video on about it not too long ago
because I heard about it from somewhere
and I was like oh my God like maybe this
is the the one good Dean Koontz
adaptation
um and it's not
it's kind of a horror movie but I think
if you liked The Frighteners uh the
Peter Jackson movie then you'll probably
really dig Odd Thomas it's very
it's a similar premise and like a
similar tone you know what I mean but
I'm not gonna say it's a rip-off because
the book Odd Thomas came out in uh a
long time ago like before The
Frighteners came out I think so but it's
kind of it's not the same but it's like
a similar kind of setup where it's just
kind of like a guy that can
see ghosts and it's kind of like
fighting them and [__] like that you
know what I mean
um let's see where the Where the Red
Fern Grows uh his books always had a
yellow lab did they really yeah Ben's
talk about elevation the lesbians next
door Kirsten that was my take
that angle hadn't even occurred to me
but maybe they did maybe they did
I don't know like I was gonna review I
was gonna review it but then I liked the
book but I was just kind of like well
it's not really horror you know what I
mean
it's not really horror
at all like it's kind of like a drama
like a comedy drama with like a Sci-Fi
angle to it so I was like so maybe I
won't and it's pretty short too so I
didn't really like think I was gonna
bother
I mean I don't necessarily always do
straight up horror because I mean the
last book review I did was like a murder
mystery but you know I do Thrillers and
stuff too but elevation I just felt like
it wasn't
enough of a horror novel for me to like
justify it so
I probably won't review it but the book
I'm reading now
I will review eventually but I'm not
done with it yet it's another
um Grady Hendrix
so I've done several of his books
already I love Grady Hendrix but um this
one I don't hear too much about this one
I think this was one of his earlier ones
called we sold our souls it's about like
a John's like a heavy metal band wasn't
that from a boy's dog no boy his dog
which I have that I have boy and his dog
on Blu-ray which of course is [__]
bootleg because nobody owns that movie
that [__] the boy in his dog is too
subversive to be owned by anybody
because sometimes you can you can find
it on on Blu-ray guys on eBay
guys burning
boy and his dog Blu-rays and I'll give
it to you in the package and everything
I bought one it's worth it boy and his
dog was John Johnson in a
post-apocalyptic movie kind of like Mad
Max and he had a dog
that I think some kind of genetically
engineered dog with some cybernetic
features in it
and the dog is like an ex-police dog and
I guess it must be very old maybe they
don't die of old age I don't know but it
was something from before the apocalypse
happened
and this whole thing is is that it could
it has sensors on it
and Don Johnson who's
a young guy [__] bolt action
rifle just like Johnny red kind of
the whole purpose of the dog is to sniff
out girls
it's a girl sniffing the girl sniffing
out dog
and Don Johnson basically [__] um
attacks him and kills him
after he sexually does his thing with
him
which is like normal behavior
yeah in in the Apocalypse
and it's a good movie
um yeah we reviewed it a long time ago
yeah it's a good movie and what ends up
happening to uh Don Johnson and his dog
is eventually they get abducted
by a Subterranean cult that's still
living in the 1950s
and they're going to use his breeding
stock
for some of their females
and that's where the trouble begins it's
a good one I don't want to [__] you
can probably see it for free on YouTube
I'm sure it's out there somewhere yeah
it's kind of a good movie it's kind of a
cult classic I've seen it turn up on 2B
I don't know if it's on there anymore
but I think it I've seen it on there
from time to time highly subversive
it's kind of like an American Mad Max
move but it doesn't have car chases it's
all on foot for the most part
and very morally Gray
John Gore says wasn't there a coon's
adaptation with Pierce Brosnan about a
cult of some sort yeah yeah but what the
[__] was the name of that thing yeah
that one was all right
I don't remember if I read the book it
was based on though like I said I read
probably like two or three Dean Koontz
books and I was just kind of like it's
not for me they're I mean they're good
but they're not
I don't know it's like the book
equivalent of like a popcorn flick it's
kind of like you watch it and it's just
like every chapter and at least this was
my perception I haven't read a lot of
his stuff so it's like every chapter
ended with this big Cliffhanger oh my
God what's gonna happen next it just
seemed very affected and it seemed very
formulaic and I wasn't about it so I
didn't read any more of his after that
but it just occurred to me that he had
written so many books and it's like they
really haven't done that many
adaptations and I feel the same way
about Peter Straub now Peter Stroud he's
kind of a different situation because
his writing is a lot more literary
but he's written some like [__]
Kick-Ass books that I think would make
really good movies like why did they
ever make Coco into a movie because that
was a great [__] book I really liked
that a lot but he's written like some
really good [__] he's written some like
real weird [__] too but like some of his
stuff I think I did a review not too
long ago about like a novella that he
had written which is called Mrs God and
um I really dug that until the end I
liked the end but I just felt like it
needed to be fleshed out I said this
needs to be a novel novel it seemed like
it was too short because I really really
liked the build up and then it seemed
like the end of it I was just like oh
everything went to banana pants like at
the end and I was like and then it just
ended and I was like all right so that's
what we're doing okay Hugo brings up
something good remember Hugo said where
is that very bottom boy and his dog
reminds me of movies like Cherry 2000
alien from LA and Tank Girl yeah it's
kind of like all the same genre it's
very similar to Cherry 2000 if you like
Cherry 2000 you probably like a great
movie great movie yeah oh not as dark
an alien from La which I have only seen
that one I've only seen it on MST that's
the one with Kathy Ireland I haven't
seen it where she her dad's an
archaeologist I see I've seen this movie
a bunch of times because it was on
Mystery Science Theater and that's
actually one of my favorite episodes
because the movie is so I love the 80s
ones they're like so funny she fought
and she's looking for her dad who's an
archaeologist and she falls in a hole
and there's like an underground
civilization which is like New Wave
Australia okay
I gotta see that one that sounds good I
want to show you all right I'm just
going to show you the MST version
because it's like super funny
um I agree with what Hugo's saying but I
would also throw the Mad Max in there
too it's like that oh dead end driving
yeah that's another one that's like that
we reviewed that one I don't love that
movie but it is along those same lines
dog does have some humorous angles to it
but [__] Don Johnson's playing a
[__] a horrible dude he's just
[__] horrible and he's the main
character yeah uh but he's living in a
[__] up world real [__] up he
doesn't know any better he's a Savage
basically
um which is interesting you didn't
really see you see a lot of movies like
that nowadays like where the main
character is like a morally gray like or
like a or a terrible person but I feel
like they didn't do that as much back
then so I think that's maybe why that
stood out and uh he's brought up Cherry
2000 another classic Cherry 2000 is
better now than it was it's aged really
well I didn't like it at the time but I
like it better yeah at the time you're
like yeah it aged well yeah but you see
it now and you're like yeah yeah that's
cool that's cool the way it was Melody
Griffith plays kind of like a Mad Max
chick who's a can go out into the dam
Wasteland she's like a guide or like a
guy in person got a badass 65 Mustang
and uh that's meant for the [__]
Wasteland and she takes this green horn
dude from [__] the city this is
post-apocalyptic to go find the robot
Warehouse so he could get the chip to re
to revive his Cherry 2000 model sex box
which is his girlfriend yeah
and it's it's it's a good flick it's got
uh some of the cast of Blade Runners in
it uh and out in the desert there's
these post-apocalyptic tribes I guess a
good way each one kind of like
has its own thing like one of them is a
bunch of like 1960s golfers living out
on a dam 60s style
motel and the motel complex or hotel
complex in the middle of the [__]
desert and they're like an open wife
swapping kind of cult and they're all
kind of yuppie-ish that was [__]
weird
um they're some of the main characters
they're like the bad guys
they're not
in Mad Max like the roadkill guys and
all the [__]
you know [__] what was his name
[__] humongous they're the bad guys
and this one it's a bunch of people who
got yuppies sex cult yep which seems
like closer to the truth yeah that's the
way you really were it's just kind of
wearing golf pants to [__] I always
avoid people wearing golf pants he had
shorts under all circumstances but it
was funny they looked real they looked
real [__] kind of like yuppieish but
they were [__] run their [__]
leader was a psychopath and [__] it's a
very creative flick and Melody Griffith
was in it before she got real famous and
she plays a sexy character I thought she
was hot as [__] when I was
bright red hair because I feel like
people think she's Cherry 2000 she's not
no she's a hunter yeah Cherry 2000 is
the sex spot they're trying to find the
the piece for the sex yeah that's not
her name or nothing she had a badass
rifle it was a stainless Mini-14 with a
suppressor on it the Falcon with a
folding like the ac556 if you guys Gun
Guys she had that uh she had a [__]
eight a [__] Dragon [__] m47
[__] wire guided missile which I
ended up shooting those when I was in
the army that was a dragon Gunner for a
while
it's a good flick good flick I liked it
Zack says okay but what's the legit
worst movie you've ever seen oh there's
so many like I said I am a an mst3k
veteran yeah so I so there's been some
bad movies on there I think probably the
worst one that they did
was
castle of Fu Manchu which actually had
Christopher Lee in it but that was its
only redeeming quality other than that
it was confusing as [__] I never had any
idea what was going on and it just
pissed me off however probably the I I
think probably the worst movie they did
was
bloodwaters of Dr Z
also known as zat which was actually
filmed in Florida and is mostly a
schlubby balding middle-aged dude
shuffling around yeah for about
45 minutes you see
bad movies are really easy to make
because all you got to do to make a bad
movie is make something boring if it's
boring it's gonna be [__] bad the
more boring it is the worse it is all
right
um the trick is to make a bad movie and
it's [__] awesome and for me that
would be
uh velocir okay because I I can't even
see that that's a bad move you gotta say
that's a great movie I love that movie
yeah like like unabashedly
it is what it is they knew what it was
and they they knew exactly how to [__]
with you did Robert say the worst movie
I've ever seen would be blackenstein
oh yeah that was pretty bad and the
reason why blackenstein was bad is
because it was disappointing
well I mean we can't all be as awesome
as blaculous Jack or scream black
[__] love The Blacklist series and I
was going yeah those two movies are
[__] awesome like legitimately
awesome oh yeah they're real good movies
I got them both on Blu-ray
so I said well let me check out
blackenstein this is gonna be this might
be pretty good no it sucked it was it
sucked because it was boring it was
awful just boring yeah yeah it was just
I mean there's worse movies made look
watch [__] case Cinema yeah that dude
digs up
I don't even know where the [__] he
finds most of this [__] there's a lot of
bad action movies he did one called
things which is a Canadian movie and
I've never seen the whole thing all the
way through like I don't think I could
sit through the whole thing
um that just looked like a couple of
hosers sat down it was like we're gonna
make a movie one weekend and like
nothing happens and it's terrible and
it's like they don't you know that they
didn't film it right it's like I don't
even know what the [__] is going on
there's ants I don't even know so there
was that but of the worst movies I've
seen like I said I think blood waters of
Dr Z is bad just because it has a great
premise like a mad scientist for
whatever reason decides he's going to
turn himself into a fish and therefore
take over the world because that's how
you do that
um and then he ends up as like this kind
of fish monster but like I said it's
mostly just like really boring like not
a lot happens it's just like a dude
shuffling around most of the time but I
will say too that the films Ed Wood gets
a lot of [__] but at least Ed Woods
movies are so like bafflingly
inept that they're really entertaining
but nobody really talks about how shitty
Coleman francis's movies are
and I think he only made three uh which
were the skydivers Red Zone Cuba what's
the other one Beast of Yucca Flats yeah
man
ah what those are a slog to sit through
they did all of them on Mystery Science
Theater and they actually did a good job
with them like they are actually made
them entertaining but I can't imagine
like sitting through them without the
riffing I was like I would probably just
like doze off I'm sure yeah oh you can
see blackenstein with the riffing I
think uh that's uh that's not MST that's
uh RiffTrax does that right
I don't know did they I think it was
Riff tracks that dude I don't remember
racetracks doing black insane thank you
Aaron Aaron sent us a Super Chat yeah
with Darren hey hey I'll watch you at
work tomorrow monthly tip thank you
thank you very much we appreciate that
we love those tips bro yeah Beast of
yucco flats I've seen and that had Tor
Johnson in it which brings me back to
the haunting episode where the guy
looked like George Johnson yeah he had
he was in that too there were some
scenes in that that I thought were funny
but it's like mostly
I don't know like Coleman francis's
movies all looked like
depression on film you know what I mean
yeah
it's just what was the other well no
what was the other one that he did that
was like had [__] John Carradine in
it I don't know but if you all haven't
seen um I don't know if you if some of
you might be new listeners
I talked about this before I think we've
actually done reviews on them you can
see the reviews here
if you haven't seen
Blacula and scream Blacula Scream the
sequel see them they're good I mean I
would recommend those to like any horror
fans because those are legit good movies
yeah it's a ridiculous title you go what
the [__] what are you talking about over
the top title it is but like you think
it's going to be super cheesy but it's
not it's they're real good real good
vampire movies they're well written uh
the acting is pretty good the stories
are good
um the guy who plays uh Blacula his real
name is Mama Waldy but Dracula called in
Blacula and that's why what was that
guy's name um [__] that actor William
Marshall William Marshall that's right
the M5 computer yeah Star Trek yeah yeah
he was he's great in it that he's a
badass I love his voice yeah and um the
second one is really good too I think it
takes place in New Orleans it has a lot
of uh [__] um voodoo voodoo yeah
which I was I really dug that I like
yeah and those two movies kind of
informed inspired a lot of Anne Rice's
books when it came to vampire culture
how would you live as a vampire would
you go out to the club well all that's
talked about although in the version
that I have a lot of [__] was cut out of
it I want to find the full edit where he
said let's go out to the club and [__]
and he goes you shall you will not do
that you know but you'll bring them back
here and they cut that part out you know
so what I'm just sitting around my slave
he goes yes he goes I'm your slave yes
you're my slave that is [__] awesome
and it's because Mama Waldy was
basically kind of symbolically a slave
master that's what that's what [__]
and he was against the slave trade
that's how he got turned into a vampire
that's it's a great [__] flick all
right both the two flicks
[__]
vampires made slaves they were slave
masters if they [__] bit somebody and
turned them into a vampire it was a
slave vampire which that's actually kind
of addressed in the movie but there were
also slave revolts which that's talked
about in in screamed back in the screen
too it's a great great flicks and that
was those were and it had that movie had
a spiritual successor
which was Eddie Murphy's movie
um a [__] uh vampire vampire in
Brooklyn which I got that too on Blu-ray
actually quite I like that I like that
movie too it does borrow some from
Dracula a bit about showing up in a boat
you know that kind of stuff but it's a
good it's a good flick I I I liked it
and they never really did a sequel to it
it did bombed at the theater
people didn't want to see it
sucked but it was it was a good movie
Sebastian brings up count yorga I've
actually I've actually been wanting to
do the count yorga movies I haven't
played in a long time I because I saw
them on one of our streaming services
the other day I'm like oh [__] we should
do this because I don't think we've done
it uh John Gore said killer shrews is a
great bad movie uh MST did that one too
and all I remember about killer shrews
is that the quote-unquote killer shrews
were actually clearly all dogs with
carpet samples like stuck on them and
they because they're and they were all
like real friendly and stuff which I
thought was very funny they were being
friendly right like dogs do and so yeah
I have carpet samples on them why why am
I covered with her oh well what am I
supposed to do I'm a very good boy can I
yeah I have a a bone or something but
yeah so it was like that and I remember
like long stretches of the movie with
like a bunch of people standing around
at a bar drinking yeah like in the house
so I remember drinking and dogs with
carpet samples that's like pretty much
all I remember for that movie like I
remember and wasn't the dude from
wasn't the dude from um
uh uh Beverly Hillbillies in that [__]
which one was that
wasn't Jethro from Beverly Hillbillies
in that movie
am I remember I haven't seen it in a
while because that's like an episode I
mean the MST episodes I've watched all
of them like multiple times but that's
when I don't revisit that much and it's
usually and it's because that movie is
so [__] boring like that's one of the
reasons that I don't watch
castle of Fu Manchu all that much
there's like you know they're still
funny like because the ripping makes
them funny but sometimes the movies are
just too much for me to take you know
what I mean it's just too
they're too slow or they're too I
actually prefer the best episodes of MST
for me are either like the 70s movies or
the 80s movies that are just like so
cheesy and like over the top that
they're just like super fun like some of
my favorite episodes are like [__]
um what was the one with the uh
that was um it was like a TV pilot what
was it called the Gemini man or
something like that with uh Ben Murphy
or whatever and uh riding with death
riding with death and that was like from
the 70s and it was just all like all
trucker lingo and it was just like that
[__] Jim Stafford was in there like
that bread necky like country singer
dude and it was just that was just a
delight like for just because that movie
was just like so cheesy it looks so bad
so I love all that kind of stuff I loved
space Mutiny which is like this weird
South African cheapy sci-fi movie and it
was just had this bodybuilder dude in it
and like everybody had aerobics gear on
and it was just like so [__] funny
and um so then there was like this Cult
of like Stevie Nicks looking [__] and
it's just it was I was just dying so I
love that kind of stuff I love oh and
soul taker that was another one like
from the 80s you know we finished the
show people listening now than they were
listening for go ahead and send this to
the chat
as well
yeah bonus show and and soul taker which
has not Martin Sheen but the relative of
Martin Sheen that's uh what's that
motherfucker's name Emilio Estevez no no
the other Estevez Joe Estevez Joe
Estevez uh who's in like a lot of and he
was in werewolf as well which is another
good episode so like I said I really
like the 70s and 80s ones those are my
favorite ones like the 50s sci-fi ones
are good too but like I said a lot of
the movies are just like you know
chubby white people standing around in
offices talking yeah you know so and
it's hard to make that entertaining they
do their best but
um somebody said let me see where it was
Jeff Hart says thank God for mst3k and
riff tracks I wonder what creators of
those bad movies would think of people
legit hacking them for entertainment
well they did have I mean they have had
some people because they're such a
cultural Touchstone they have actually
had some filmmakers that contacted them
and said hey can you do our movie I
think probably the most famous example
of that was um time Chasers which was
made by a bunch of people in Vermont
and was about a guy like a high school
science teacher I think he was and he
invented a time machine like out of a
biplane or something well it was like a
biplane that had like a computer it was
like on a floppy disk he invented his
time machine with a flop yeah yeah so
you know what I mean and um and it's not
a terrible movie I mean it's it's cheesy
it's worse there's way worse I mean at
least it's entertaining and [__] happens
and stuff I think it I think it was made
in the mid 90s or early 90s without Rift
tracks no one would know Manos hands of
fate right without MST because that was
one of their most famous episodes yeah I
don't I think that movie would have been
totally forgotten about if they hadn't
done because that was one of their most
iconic earlier episodes yeah and it's a
great movie when people are riffing on
it I was [__] just we saw that [__]
live on yeah riff tracks live did a
version of it the theater all right and
we were dying I was [__] my face was
falling the [__] walls man my face
hurts
I think that the because we go to rip
tracks live they have them like a few
times a year so whenever they have them
at the theater we go and see them I
think the Manos one
and burdemic were the best ones yeah man
blew my [__] mind man they [__]
they they really like [__] reamed for
them I would like to see a Neil Marine
flick they should do I wonder have they
done one well because like I said they
don't
um you know there's if you have to be
which is free they have a [__] ton of
Riff tracks on there yeah and they've
done a bunch of movies I mean I've seen
probably most of the ones that are on 2B
yeah the the the the the the Filipino
guy that did [__] uh birdemic yeah
his shit's terrible okay it is it's just
[__] terrible it'd be unwatchable
with that with Rift tracks riffing on it
but
who might be worse
because the movies are a little more
coherent
and they actually take themselves a
little bit more seriously would be a
deal braid and he stars in every one of
his movies as just a universal sex
symbol and he's like always usually
something like Messiah figures Messiah
figure that's good it's really something
all the girls love him and when you see
the dude
he's like a very very average
middle-aged man very average
and it's just maybe he's got magic sting
lingam Powers Yeah it's like Sting
sitting up here
sitting in a Lotus position women just
throwing themselves upon his erect
legume
to [__] getting that he's got them
all stacked up you know yeah you got
them stacked up one on top just like top
you up just like one of those toddler
toys that has that thing that you put
like the little yeah donut things on but
exhibits women on on one dude's dick
[__] sting man
you're welcome for that image by the way
yeah although I I [__] with steak
every time I talk about things cool I
like steak Yeah he can act he can act
and I think he was mostly taking the
piss
yeah yeah
I don't think he takes himself all that
spiritual ass [__] come on right
I just think he's being funny yeah but
yeah so I don't know I mean I'm I would
be very surprised if riff tracks hadn't
done some Neil Breen you know because
they've done so many movies they don't I
mean they don't just do like shitty ones
they do like big budget ones too but
usually you have to pay for those
but how it works if you don't know is
that you go to their website and you
download their
um
their audio track and then if you have
the movie at home like you can watch the
movie at home and you can sync up the
audio track you download if it's like a
couple of bucks or something and then
like you can watch along like with the
and but sometimes like on 2B and
sometimes on their YouTube channel they
have
um some that are already synced up like
movies that are not you know copyrighted
or anything like that so there's a bunch
of them on 2B though
um including I don't remember if
birdemic is I think the birdamic live
one is on there actually now that I'm
thinking about it and the Manos live
might be on there too because some of
their live shows are archived on 2B they
definitely have the dude that did
birdemic
um James Nguyen that's what his name is
um he did another movie called the [__]
was the name of that replicas or
something something like that and he did
one and they and that movie is also
baffling not quite as batshit as
birdemic was like not quite as crazy or
because it's more like a Sci-Fi
relationship drama yeah his name is Gwen
when it's yeah
well it's that that name good g-u-e yeah
but I think you just pronounced that
Nguyen or something like that I can't
remember like well one thing about it
you don't pronounce it the way it looks
he's not Western you know uh he's an
Eastern guy
from the Philippines and he has this uh
strange
con he's got this strange [__] kind
of like
preconceived notion about the way
westerners date
okay and what white girls do
most of it revolves around sitting
around sitting on people's laps
you always see
he must have a fetish for that or
something it's a white couple oh did you
hear that yeah and the girl is sitting
on his lap straddling him sitting on his
lap I remember correctly or is he just
sitting on laps that's what dating is
sitting on laps well the whole weird
thing about that scene was the dude was
like laying on the couch and she and
they weren't like having sex or anything
they were fully clothed yeah and they
weren't doing anything she was just like
sitting there and then another thing is
is that he believes that white dudes
meet women by seeing them in public like
in a mall and then following them home
and knocking on their doors I saw you at
the moment
he will get your ass shot okay if you
follow a woman home or at the very least
get your ass arrested yeah very least
yeah we used to for sure get maced in
the South you could probably get shot
you would probably get shot yeah yeah if
you if you pull that come at you who are
you I remember you yeah who the [__] are
you freaking only why are you following
me only a rapist is gonna do that that's
what I'm saying what the [__] normal
person like follows you home like
follows you to your house you are a
[__] crazy yeah that's follow a woman
that is not okay across town
to her house I just wanted to tell you
how beautiful you are blah blah blah
[Laughter]
I signed them all a half hour ago
followed you home
I mean pretty much you'd get shot and I
mean kind of like so really
cop shot what happened he followed me
all the way from the mall this
[__] trying to get it
holy [__] that's a rapist
go about your business baby well you
saved us all a lot of trouble
pretty much so yeah there's that yeah
all right yeah new one new one yeah
something like that you gotta see more
of his [__] that motherfucker's out oh
you if you want me to I'll show you that
other one that was on because they did a
couple of his movies like on uh Rift
tracks yeah and I think all of them are
on I think they did like three of his
movies I almost want a neo-breen
collection too
yeah I wonder how much he wants for
those [__] what if he sells a box set
probably yeah he probably wants 100
bucks for them [__] too oh I bet he
does he seems like the kind of episode
he really does he actually uh had like a
seminar where people a big show where
people came to see him and when he
walked out it was like thunderous
Applause and he took the [__] seriously
he does have a fan base but it's because
he's so [__] freaky he's [__]
weird I don't think he gets it
I don't think he gets it MST made him
famous
yeah yeah
he because he takes himself very
seriously a serious filmmaker
he's a hack
yeah wow kind of weird
I mean yeah I don't know I don't know
how to feel about that level of
cluelessness yeah
it's like it's nice to like believe in
yourself and stuff like artistically and
whatnot but I mean you do have to know
when you're the butt of the joke right
yeah they're not mock
but they like him because he's [__]
weird I will know what I was gonna say
previously was that um when I was
talking about the makers of time Chasers
the uh which was made in the I think it
was made in the early 90s I want to say
like 92 94 something like that and they
actually brought the film to the
attention of mst3k mst3k did the movie
and it's a great Episode by the way
because it's not a terrible movie it's
actually like pretty competently made
and stuff but there's a lot to make fun
of you know because they always find
something and I think that they I don't
think the filmmakers expected them to
kind of roast it the way they did Even
though that's kind of what they do but I
think they kind of like were okay with
it after however
one person that I've heard was not okay
with him mocking his movies was Joe Don
Baker because they did a couple of his
movies they did Mitchell
um that was Joel's last episode back in
season five and then they did final
Justice which is another one of my very
favorite episodes in final Justice Joe
Don Baker plays a Texas
God like a Texas law person guy what do
you think Texas Rangers I don't think
it's Ranger right yeah whatever like
yeah like the Chuck Norris show yeah
yeah like he plays one of those and he
somehow which wouldn't happen because of
jurisdictional issues I'm sure but he
ends up going to Malta well he's
supposed to go to Italy but then they
get diverted to Malta it's a whole big
thing like where he's like following
some mobster and he killed his brother
and it's his big thing so it's Joe Don
Baker wearing a ridiculous cowboy
costume
on Malta
and it is the stupidest silliest and one
of the plot points in the movie is that
Joe Don Baker is like dyspeptic or
something and so like every time he goes
to a bar like there's a running gag
where he's just always asking for a
glass of milk and like people are making
fun of him and [__] because it's like he
has indigestion and it's like so and
he's kind of fat in this one too you
know what I mean so so they made like a
lot of fat jokes they made like a lot of
he's gonna eat everything jokes they
made jokes about the milk and everything
like that I mean it's a hilarious
hilarious episode now I think after they
did Mitchell and they weren't even as
mean to him they were mean to him as in
Mitchell but that was Joel and he wasn't
as mean as Mike like the second host
because Mike is much meaner but uh Joe
Don Baker apparently ran into them like
at some convention or something like
that and they heard through the
grapevine that Joe Don Baker wanted to
kick all their asses like because he saw
what they did with Mitchell and so Props
to the mst3k guys they so Judo Baker was
going to kick their asses for Mitchell
which like I said they were mean to him
but not that mean so when they did
another Joe Don Baker movie final
Justice they were even mean early
I mean they just [__] but they've
just [__] drilled down it I mean they
were just terrible I mean they just like
even over the over the end credits like
they made up a song about him just like
eating everything oh my God it's like
it's so [__] funny and I mean it's
really mean-spirited but it's like you
have to laugh because he couldn't take a
joke yeah you know what I mean so it's
like I thought it was funny that they're
like man just [__] off you're not gonna
be and it's like even in because I have
the um the Mystery Science Theater
episode guide and they even said and I
can't remember exactly where this but it
was like [__] hilarious they wrote
about the show and they said yeah we
heard through the grapevine that jaydon
Baker wanted to beat all her asses and
um it's like yeah well bring it on
because it's like he'd probably take a
swing spill his drink all over his
rented arm candy escort and like also
they were like really nice
you like they said this really hard [__]
and I was like I love that they just
like [__] piled on like that because
some people had like I said some people
were happy
you know like the um the the daughter of
the um the guy that played The Master in
Manos she actually makes a whole living
now like going to conventions and like
talking about Manos and making the the
weird like Manos like yeah cloak and
whatever yeah she tries to sell videos
guys right right and stuff like that um
so that would not have been possible if
they had not done because I think
everybody just would have forgotten
about that movie that movie I kind of
wish it's a great premise
um it's really hampered by
incompetence you know I have today but
it's a good idea
and so I kind of wish that somebody
would sort of remake that
because it's a great idea but it's just
the guy what he had a camera that only
could film like 30 seconds at a time and
didn't have synced audio
so it's like so everybody that's talking
in the movie is off screen
so there's like weird shots where
somebody's talking off screen and then
you have a shot of somebody just like
standing there looking at the camera you
know what I mean it's bizarre but I
don't know but there was something about
it that resonated with everybody because
that's like one of the most iconic
episodes I'm gonna put this up I'm
losing power
yeah yeah
I mean like one of the one of the most
uh one of the most famous I think jokes
they made about Manos was
Joel's that like the movie had only just
started it was only like five or ten
minutes in and he says something like
every frame of this movie looks like
someone's last note photograph
which is actually like really perceptive
that's exactly what this movie looks
like it just looks like it shouldn't
exist but it does so that's why it's
like kind of fascinating to me but I
don't I can't imagine watching it
without them joking about it though
because
I don't know maybe it's weird enough
maybe it's weird enough some of the
movies on there I wouldn't mind watching
them
without it I mean it's always better
with them joking about it but some of
the movies on there I think are like
legit
pretty decent movies or are at least are
entertaining enough on their own I'm
talking about
actually one of the best movies that
they did
was from I think it was from the 50s or
maybe early 60s and it was called the
girl in Lovers Lane it was like a
thriller
and that was I would argue that that was
like legitimately a good movie for the
time and they said they felt kind of bad
about it like that they I don't know if
they felt bad about it but they were
like this was actually like one of the
best movies we ever did and it's
actually like a decent movie
um but then there's also stuff like I
love the Russo finish like fantasy
movies that they did like the day the
Earth froze
um Jack Frost I could legit watch that
one without
it's better with their [__] in it
because it's like wave on air because
it's ridiculous but they're so over the
top like with all these crazy costumes
and witches and all this other kind of
stuff so it's just like fun without that
but movies that are just like really
dull or boring I think they really need
that
but I don't know if they have like a
bunch of crazy [__] going on there too
they have a lot more to work with
what's coming down out there Zach says
the only reason I know who Jadon Baker
is is because he was in a couple Bond
movies yeah Jonah Baker was in some
decent movies but
he was also in final Justice which is
uh not a good movie
in fact it's a pretty stupid and
ridiculous movie but you know made by
good old Braden Clark oh another one
um that's like 80s that I think was like
a really good episode was hobgoblins
which has to be one of the most 80s
movies ever [__] made it is so 80s
that you will just
there's just so much neon and big
crimped hair and
there's little Gremlin puppets rubbing
themselves on people like looking like
they're attacking them it's it's
hysterical it's it's a terrible movie
but it's also like pretty entertaining
and there's a a nightclub in there which
is supposed to be like a not supposed to
be a golf club but it's supposed to be
like this rough Punk Club where people
get murdered in this fight yeah so and
it's called rockers were dangerous and
it's called Club scum
and you go in there and it's clearly
like a high school cafeteria which has
been like where they put like some dark
lights in there and [__] like that it's
just oh my God it's it's [__]
hysterical like the [__] that they do
but yeah that was a good one too all
right so maybe we should wrap this up
because it's we've gone way over time 9
30 and it's like I gotta go to bed soon
because I'm gonna get up early in the
morning uh but yeah so we seem to have
wandered far afield from Haunting but
you know that's how we do so uh so yeah
so Wednesday night as I mentioned
the show that we're gonna do we're gonna
do a a Long Island serial killer recap
and update because they have uh pretty
much they think they caught the guy yeah
I mean
yeah I'd be very very surprised if it
wasn't no dude because they've been
working on it for more than a year like
getting all the evidence and stuff so
I'm pretty sure they got all their T's
crossed in their eyes this case in one
of your books didn't you
no because
um this happened later too late okay
yeah it happened too late but we did a
show about it back in 2018. okay
um when it was unsolved when they had no
idea who it was and the crazy thing
about it is that this dude that they
caught was not even one of the suspects
that they had on the radar like so they
only just figured out who it was like a
year ago or something like that yeah it
is your boss pretty much yeah I mean
it's not my boss because my boss is the
boss my boss is a little tiny woman with
a raspy voice and a weird manicure but
um you know what I mean
but he looks like somebody's boss
somebody's boss like well I guess he was
somebody's boss because he owned an
architecture for him but yeah so we're
gonna do a Long Island serial killer
recap update all that kind of stuff on
the Wednesday night show so hopefully
you guys can join us for that
that should be pretty fun uh and yeah so
hopefully you guys have a good rest of
your evening have a good day tomorrow
and we'll oh and thanks for all your
super chats because we got some bunch of
super chats tonight so that was cool so
we'll see you guys again on Wednesday
night good